[Music]
the most elite event in online chess
returns with more than a hundred
thousand dollars in prizes the speed
chess championship is bigger and better
than ever as players trying to qualify
their way in through the women's and
juniors field we take a look ahead and
see who's on deck waiting amongst the
seated players of course right there at
the top you have defending champion
Hikaru Nakamura he'll face a familiar
cast of foes and guys like yonder pom
Yoshi Alexander Grisham young Christoph
Duda and more but perhaps his biggest
challenger will be a brand new player in
the field currently the world number
three and the top chess player from
China
ding li Ren at 2809 looks to make his
SCC debut a memorable one look ahead and
mark your calendars for November 29
through December 1st where the
semifinals and finals will happen you
can follow all the action at twitch.tv
slash chess chess comm TV or go to
speech Chess Championship comm to stay
up to date with all the latest news and
info be sure to fill out your fantasy
bracket and try to predict who's gonna
win this year's speech Chess
Championship and we'll see you on chefs
calm
and we are live with another edition of
the junior speech Chess Championship
brought to you by Cheska comm with me
the one and only Grandmaster Eric Hanson
who I think of all the the most
appropriate hosts to have today someone
who was thrown down against these guys
on a regular basis on chess calm how
excited are you to see what Olli reason
firoozeh is capable of in this format
and and thanks for being here then ever
you ever intended to he's pretty good
right never intended to and one thing
about these juniors Danny's they're
willing to play like all day every day
side of things so I'm glad to actually
be talking about the games instead of
pretty my risk we're glad to have you
let's let's remind everybody of what it
is that we do here during the speech s
championship we face off 16 of the
world's best juniors in a knockout
bracket format obviously last week we
had the first match go down in an
absolute nail-biter thrilling thrilling
match there between your and Vaughn for
East and re ontari with Vaughn phoresis
moving on today of course we have
Aubrey's a firoozeh taking on Jose
Eduardo Martinez Alcantara I think it's
pretty obvious Eric that a lot of people
feel like all the Ariza is not only the
favorite in today's match but I think
many people's favorite to maybe win the
whole thing
your thoughts though on how the
increment might affect the four seed
against the 13 seed today people think
today's match Martinez Alcantara is just
a favorite on the whole field right
based on recent performances like in the
World Championships I'm and just as
overall you know his bliss ratings and
you know his matches Indian cigar I
think the increments certainly produces
the higher quality chess and it's a bit
more even there because I'm introverted
like 30 to 30 or under bullet and that's
particularly and that's zero right not
gonna be a hyper bullet flagging fest
today and on that note I mentioned
so let's talk about the rules remind
everybody of what goes down in these
speech chess championship matches the
junior event brought to you by chess kid
is not really any different than the
main speech has formats you've been
seeing for the last few years as we said
there are increment in each different
segments the five one three one and then
one one as we said it's a bracket that
is seated by the feet a ratings based on
March 2019 for those of you wondering
why people are seated the way they are
of course the bracket features sixteen
of the world's best juniors and it's
single elimination we move forward
because what they're playing for is a
lot of prize money and let's talk about
that of course these kids play a lot of
chess online but they don't normally
play for these kind of prizes Eric how
much do you wish when you were fifteen
there were opportunities like this as a
junior to to throw down for 20 grand and
a chance to play in the main speech s
championship you can you can brag to
your friends pretty well with Rises like
that I think I think that's how you make
chess school you know when when guys are
in high school winning sports
competitions is one thing but in chess
these guys are playing for cash right no
it's a good point right the the athletes
and baseball are playing for pride at
best all right these guys got cash money
to blink that's a lot of I don't know
that's a lot of shoes you can buy in
high school but today's players let's
talk about who the matchup is of course
firoozeh versus martinez Alcantara we've
got the smarter chess match predictions
in front of us here Eric and as we break
this thing down is really not that big
of a surprise I pretty much make a habit
of criticizing these predictions on a
weekly basis but somehow they often hold
true including last week where I said
there's no way that Vaughn Far East is
not a heavy favorite and bullet he ended
up winning the match but it was the one
portion he actually lost so this
prediction is saying that faroush is the
favorite anything that stands out to you
there about the different time control
segments or is it pretty much what you
expected that Ali Riza faroush is is
kind of the favorite overall in in this
format this one I think those players
they play very frequent
online there's a good sample size
where's like last week I wasn't sure how
tired we do it's more like because we
don't know I mean maybe he was working
while I'm doing that we didn't know
about so this week I feel a bit more
confident being familiar to the players
and intrusion just I I don't see a
weakness in his game that I think the
field can exploit like a particular time
control yeah no it is you know the one
thing that I'll say is I'll be curious
how the increment plays out as you said
we definitely know the faroush is gonna
be the favorite he plays so much on
chess calm often throws down against the
world's best but but again they you know
we see it a lot in the SEC right the
increment is is a bit of a game changer
I think it levels out some of those some
of those pure mouse and flagging skills
and it allows the chess to speak a
little more of course Purusha is still a
very strong chess player but we'll see
how he matches up on the X's and O's
against Martinez Alcantara today so
we're actually gonna get the game
started here in just a few moments after
a very very quick break so everyone if
you're with us please don't go anywhere
when we return we have the players
sitting right below us we've got the
legendary curtains that I picked out
myself for ollie rhesus air in case
you're wondering I picked those out and
Alcantara is rocking some some snazzy
headphones so we're gonna be right back
and when we do the games will begin in
our second juniors B Chess Championship
match of the year brought to you by
Jessica calm
[Music]
and we are back here for the second
match of the year it's the junior speech
s championship brought to you by chess
kit.com Grandmaster Eric Hanson the
twitch chat is alive and well thank you
to everyone that is here and and we are
we are pretty much ready we just had a
donation the show hasn't even started
yet Thank You HP Foreman 3m I'm
following the players and the games have
begun Eric we have liftoff with ali riza
fairuza
getting the white pieces to start things
for go for i pretty much played in the
first juniors speech as I played against
the Conrad bull there was one of the
first matches that was like our third
ever yes we ever did of this format
right that's right how old were you in
that match good though that was a blast
and I remember I remember that match and
I think that you know we we didn't
really realize then how kind of unique
and how fun this format was you know you
talked about the timer ticking down adds
an element that we don't always have in
normal chess events right you've got
something where that you know when in
those close matches that adds an element
that is very much you know traditional
sports the race against the clock along
with your opponent and I think just
overall we've we've seen this thing grow
and and and they've been a ton of fun
but yeah hey that's just remember shakin
for the players here we'll share
Martinez Alcantara he don't think he
played and you know the Jesus probably
used to the webcam and the big crowds
I can't imagine his you know thrown to
me events like this and chance Andrews
still adjusting to the spotlight ya know
he's he's obviously grabbed a lot more
of the spotlight I think for this last
year and a half he's been streaming he
had out to all the subscribers all the
early support we're having we're not
gonna be able to yell yell out
everyone's name
but we love you we appreciate you but
yeah I mean now I think he's probably a
little more use now to the big to the
big formats but but this is this is a
little different spot Eric he's often
the underdog gets to kind of be that kid
can he beat hit karo today right or can
what can he do and now it's like he's
supposed to win this match right and and
that's a different type of pressure and
talk about the nerves you had when you
play the first time and how do you
handle that I mean when you're the
favorite it's a totally different
experience than when you've really had
nothing to lose right getting a good
start and probably not taking two
measures early on just knowing you know
I think aid in yourself you're basing
consistent good chess and we have you in
a position like this I mean it makes a
lot of sense not to go necessarily right
out of the gates with something really
sharp this is a bit of a positional
approach against the Sicilian I just
think you know you're not necessarily
sure that you're gonna win right off
right away but just not giving your
phone a much counter play playing your
own game there's no reason to mess up
himself against he just plays himself
this plan of night see one the idea is
to maybe remove the the bad Soviet Pony
and try to play for B 3 and C 4 is this
the idea to kind of clamp down black
spawns on the dark squares er is the
plan just a more aggressively maneuver
to d3 b4 and bring a new piece into d5
[Music]
this looks slow I mean I'm not okay I
don't play this line is Wi-Fi did you
play the night off his black and if I
was just you know making my assessment
of the position I would agree with you
that it feels like even though Perugia
took a took a safe approach we talked
about nerves that maybe that doesn't
mean it was the most accurate approach I
mean here I think black can still play
b5 and it's gonna be hard for white to
stop the breakthrough of d5 right
like that separate blocks making
argument that that is already better so
already I would say that I mean when you
look at increment out of the increment
and what the time controls you should
think that maybe 5 1 is where Martinez
Alcantara right and has the best chances
playing the best chess nothing worried
about for speed as much so this is this
is what I would expect to be the closest
format
the one thing I've known that I'd played
both players quite a bit is that crews
still can tell he just it's harder to
beat so he doesn't tilt as much because
you got a blood first
whereas Martinez Alcantara very stable
player and yes it really doesn't tilt so
much very very consistent in that sense
so it's a great insight from somebody
who plays these guys a lot you talk
about tilt I mean all the top players
have mentioned that in this format
that's what makes the SEC so interesting
that you don't have time to recover I
mean of course you guys play hours and
flits and bullet but but playing playing
hours and blitzen bullet when you don't
even have the option to take a break
right because if you find yourself
tilting you you can't take a break you
can choose not to in this format you
can't take a break right and so you said
off the air and all share a little bit
of that insight if that's ok with you
for the fans
Eric Eric said he really feels like
early on in the match this might be a
sign where if Alcantara can keep his
tempo early on and not allow Ollie risa
to to be feeling it right that's gonna
really I think say a lot about where the
match is headed because these guys are
young even even firoozeh is capable of
tilt and bullets so you really feel like
early on this is kind of key for
Alcantara to start out well you can
definitely score score wins here and I
think I think that's the key to start
out well because he's in good form he's
just fast and burns really well full of
confidence and it feels like a transient
in the u.s. full-speed but but when he
gets frustrated stellastot has
frustrations right the emotions can be
real right emotions out the chest broad
like family
should have like a thing about that like
how you talk with people about like
dealing with emotions like during big
blitz mashes and streams right because
you're an expert on that matter I mean
you have like a therapist like lounge
there a couch where people lay down and
talk about talk about the chest tilt
that's we don't have things that tilt
outside of online but online it's it's
just a never-ending ya know it's like
I'm in a video game you know when you're
in these matches like sometimes you're
in a video game and you just trying to
get out of that yeah well we'll talk
about the particular position here now
we we highlighted the the plan that
might come to fruition looks like it did
all the reason managed to get this night
to before which I think Eric and I both
agreed it felt like a slow plan to do
the full ream maneuver but he pulled it
off and now Alcantara has to worry about
the b-pawn and he doesn't have the
ability to punch d5 through anymore this
is a very common positional need for
black in this structure to to both
liberate the pieces behind the pawn like
the missions and also prevent white from
just sticking it on the light square so
what do you think over this is gone I
look at time and that's been very equal
this whole game all the reason has a
small edge here but what are your
thoughts do you still feel like Alcantar
is in a good spot or or you feel like
all the reasons slow play and played off
consistency a lot of the best players
what they do is they make small mistakes
but they don't blunder pieces or
anything that's game-changing and if
Martinez dagger can just
continue what he's doing right now at
this at this rate that's good but I
would say that phone behind analog is
just the big no ago I watched yesterday
fusion he's lost a few notches the guy's
not a ninja Carter doesn't happen very
often like one of those players is Dan
you know we can get his number on a good
day that when Dan is doing well he's
fast
he's aggressive right he just doesn't
bother you can play just really really
good speech I said and that's this tiny
dance routine isn't bruised I'm just
gonna say how much is time and indicator
of form right we say that class is
permanent form is temporary right and we
you see these guys usually it's not just
about the position or how quickly you
see the tactics kind of jumping out
jumping on their board it's it's their
clock management right so how often can
you like tell early on whether someone
is in ideal form based on not just that
they're playing good chess but they're
always up on the clock when it matters
you know the first thing but overall I
mean stronger players should play faster
they're good right to simply go to their
heads quicker and so if you see a strong
player like taking way too much time
it's usually a sign of a lack of
confidence because right certainly
capable of instinctively playing
excellent moves that's a great point I
haven't thought about the lack of
confidence thing as much I was thinking
of you know maybe the form is off as far
as the X's and O's but that's a great
point just the psychological aspect of
confidence and nerves and really really
playing a big part in terms of how you
feel that day all right well this is
getting heating up now I mean Alchemist
no no under under 30 seconds maybe he
played shuffle puck a little too long we
were seeing moves like you know the
bishops kind of just going back and
forth here and not really not really
making any concrete decision with how to
handle the light scores and now firoozeh
has really played aggressive with f4 but
here comes d5 bad time management he 5
but he takes on d5 I guess maybe he's
spying potential back rank ideas - he's
not afraid of just playing counter play
right because he's willing to just
calculate it through so that's what he's
done he takes me by here sure that opens
up my efile a little bit or or somehow
losing things up but that's upon and I
don't see any tactic there so I'm gonna
go ahead even if it makes my opponent
happier - do you think that's something
that the younger players and generation
just do better and better just play
frankly more like computers right
because they raised in an era where they
know that you can make conquer
even if they look ugly actually that's
something that they just do better and
better with every with every new
generation yeah and here is just over
yeah speaking of concrete moves faroush
you just delivered a concrete blow there
that was a it was a nice victory to
start this thing off and Wow all right
Game one in the books and firoozeh is up
one to nothing really on but you don't
want to see that cost management from
from Martinez Alcantar that just you
know possibility there to generate
counter play when you have 15 seconds
how can you how can you see that's a
sign of form or just nerves right you
mention him nervous these guys can be to
start but no I agree because his
position was good right it was a solid
nine or if nothing's nothing spectacular
from from firoozeh but Alcantara was
just under twenty seconds in an equal
position and that's what happens to
that's what happens to you to you as a
chess player so all right all right now
we're in a mainline Spanish we'll see if
he can fix the mistake of how slowly he
played last game this is this is a
little more your alley right isn't to
something up here up your repertoire if
that's annamarie based your repertoire
one thing that both players when they
have bad positions are still very
bicycle they play quickly they don't let
their time see try to solve it just like
it's a bad position we'll just play boss
let my opponent do the work that will
ask version knew he didn't have a great
story he just played quickly and just
Martinez burned way too much bar trying
to think about the optimal way of trying
to you know I play that Sicilian
just was not a possible choice we'll see
that yeah no I mean it'll be interesting
to see whether this continues right now
Jos bum meaning Martinez Alcantar is
even more down on time than he was in
the last game but we have even more
opportunities to engage with our fans
and social media these days than ever
before
first shout out to our daily question
which we always have and today we have
that of all the J SCC competitors who do
you think has the best chance of
becoming a future world chess champion
we get this conversation a lot Eric we
actually asked every single one of our
participants this and the the one of one
of the players getting and getting more
votes than you would think was actually
Benjamin litora the young Hungarian but
let me ask you I mean what are you when
you look at this field you got guys like
Wei Yi obviously all the recent fairuza
gets a lot of love from the chest comm
fans of course everybody get involved on
social media use the hashtag speech
doesn't give us your opinion but I
expect this to be a popular one today I
mean who do you think or I'll ask you
maybe a slight a slightly different
follow-up day the question what is the
real indicator if someone has that
potential sometimes we look at 2650 by
18 or whatever but really I think and a
lot of ways it's it's you know the
future has been are you over twenty
seven twenty by twenty one years old or
something right like what do you think
is that is that indicator of not just
that they're obviously a very talented
junior but they they clearly are showing
like the ability to get in with the big
boys and stay there what what do you is
that is that benchmark something that I
look for because even those rating goals
most of those prodigies obviously never
be world champion and maybe whatever it
means out ten one thing that I do look
for is is that ambition when you're
playing top players you're honestly not
going for draws you're trying to take it
as I get investment I am playing these
guys I want to extract the most from the
games I want to I want to try to push
these guys and you're not really almost
settling and as a professional you're
still sort of just just trying to do it
yourself to the maximum before I ever
really like being like a guy was like
playing the burly and we're trying to
just be a correct chest but so I
definitely look for like
yeah just the fighting spirit right
answer because to me that's a very
that's a very truthful answer in regards
to what we saw with Magnus Carlsen at a
young age right you see these guys with
it's not about whether they gain rating
points right it's about they want the
2800 scalp at that 2500 right and
they're not taking draws and I love that
answer that's a great point let us know
your thoughts about it in the twitch
chat or on social media everybody use
the hashtag speed chess and give us your
opinion on the on the daily question
there and again shout out to all of you
we got about 1400 of you with us and the
day has only just begun so unfortunately
for Martinez Alcantara if he doesn't fix
things it's gonna be a long day because
this just looks like he's getting
smashed Derek he's a gallon and 4 is in
a great position
everyone just hits the queen there's no
time for any in Queen age 5 because yeah
see to tanging you can just block the
diagonals lost a lot of pieces for the
Queen that would be yeah yeah okay and
he finds this and actually actually that
was the problem so much you know that I
feel Queen and King GA then you would
love to play Queen e4 check and then
take the knight and the Queen Intermezzo
but you can't take both at once
everybody because if I'd have had f5
they're just simply winning into these
turrets and the piece work we like also
has this Queen side majority that's
coming pretty quickly yeah this Bishop
here and the b2 bond combined with B 4
and C 3 coming it just this seems like
it's gonna be way too many pieces for
the for the lady I'd handle that much
time as any player and the correct moves
and and he refuses just has two puzzle
choices it gives the Kings more
breathing room
[Music]
I like your mood better because I
thought that keeping the other Brooke
behind the Queen side also made sense
for B 4 and C 3 coming but probably
this point where we're picking between
flavours of winning right yeah
so the one outside chance
Martinez Alcantar would have an
obsession like this everyone is that you
know blacks King is not perfectly safe
and well I don't think that's really
gonna lead to a mating net let's say
with Knight g5 I think that if black
deals with something like Knight f6
check and we just trade off this dark
square Bishop you may see you may see
real chances for a perpetual which might
be the one way the white saves this I
think that one area the Queen can
sometimes hold her own against a whole
lot of pieces is is against an open King
and so we'll see if Jocelyn can create
some counter play here yeah definitely
perpetual you should only good day if
you can get rid of that dark there's a
bunch of stuff and the King will be a
little exposed but it's hard to it's
hard to see it right I don't know I
don't see the request operation probably
some people miss the past like g3 or age
for just yeah it's it's so slow you need
to you have h4 h5 and what's he going
for here he's got a trick in mind one
thing about the Queen on h4 it's kind of
holding back the Queen side expansion
currently hitting the c4 pawn but I'm
gonna guess all the reason calculates
and maybe calls his bluff and says I'm
just gonna take the B to pawn where's
the mate yeah yeah and this is this is
gonna be a tough start I mean you and I
talked about how important it might be
to start off this match for further for
Martinez Alcantara in a in a positive
light not allow this thing to get away
from you as many people feel but you
know the shorter the time controls the
more all the reason becomes the favorite
right so shout out to our stats there
we've had so many great questions feed
in master Mike Klein who runs the show
over the over there Cheska calm our
sponsor for the junior speech has
championship caught up with all these
players will be bringing you little
anecdotes and answers they gave to the
different questions all day so watch the
stat line there and
get it get a little bit more information
about these young kids get to know him
right you never know they may become a
real champion so if you become a fan now
right then you really feel like you know
these kids it's a little funny this
approach Cruz is going for me or some
try and punish White's King where I was
maybe someone else would just bring the
knight back to d3 chill just put the
pieces on good squares and and you know
bit of a lazy way of converting but also
the safe human way right you talk about
firoozeh note is not afraid to mix it up
plays very much like a computer I think
a sign of so many of the the best
juniors these days is they're willing to
be to be crazy but but also it could
backfire right because if you get
yourself in trouble and you don't
convert now you've got the rook on a
loose square meaning an undefended
square I don't know I feel the same way
you do maybe that's just the old dog
look at us we're getting the old Erica
is in this approach but maybe firuze is
just gonna made him the queen and your
pieces aren't protecting themselves and
your King is hope and that's what you
that's what plungers happen loose teeth
as you pointed out you're definitely
setting yourself up for a higher chance
of making a blunder but he's obviously
confident and all that that's just not
gonna happen
he's just like I don't mind doing that
cuz I just won't plunder whereas for
everyone else we've blended 10,000 times
in America
oh definitely capable of that sort of
blender yeah let's just put the pieces
on safe secure good squares and let the
gameplay itself but here here he's
trying to set up something to stop the
move Bishop e5 that was coming on the
borscht out out your boy a friend of
both urine you and me video chess that's
Gujarati top player Foreman you hanging
on the twitch at vintage chess make sure
you guys give him give him heck while
he's here about about his streaming
channel that the chest not comms been
helping him set up right vid it we see
you baby we want you we want you on
Twitch community wants you he's been
alright winning 4 for 10 moves and this
has many easy ways right and that's
where you get yourself in trouble with
that approach
we were saying I mean yes it was the
lazy approach but putting all your
pieces on safe squares making moves you
can almost pre move that would be the
carpeau vien way to convert on this but
you know these guys at least for now
firoozeh finally takes that pawn and but
did he get himself in a little bit of
trouble before he did I mean this is
where it gets crazy cuz now
okay black should still be better but
when the Queen has his ability to poke
at a loose King and help a pawn push you
have to be careful although the more I
look at it I think I think finally if
Rouge you just coordinated and now here
comes rook c7 and then c2 and I think
it's over him he's gonna find it so yeah
alright well we we you know we question
Dan is for very strategical and that he
actually took a sweet time because just
like well you're not gonna resign okay
I'll play this I'll just drain the clock
while putting up points well I think
first of all I think it's a fascinating
point I think that would be that would
be full match strategy and for those of
you who are not quite following what
Eric said so obviously the the the
speeches championship is broken down
into three segments right in some ways
we call it call it the three disciplines
of online blitzen bullet mastery right
you've got the 5-minute so you gotta you
gotta have that balance of super high
quality chests you can't rely on time
scrambles the three minutes somewhere in
the middle and then the bullet and I
think that if you feel that you're
really the favorite as the gloves come
off and the time control it would stand
to reason that you should milk as much
time off of a total game clock there we
see we have an hour and six minutes left
right now to get to the faster time so
thank you Jackie - sweet thank you to
everybody that's with us whether you're
watching at chest out comm TV twitch TV
slash chest the cheers coming in we love
you look at the love being here and look
version had to had to uh had to do
something there may it looks like he had
to go get some hopefully that's not an
adult beverage there he is only 12 after
all but he's fresh he's got the beverage
that he needed apparently Danny when
some people are listening to us they
need an adult beverage
hey you know what you sometimes we Nina
Dobrev it's just just to listen to
ourselves out out to e Linda our diamond
member one of the old old G's of chess
calm hanging out there in the chat
what's up Eric easiest to beat and
everybody else in the chef's TV jihad
thanks for being here all right so we've
got a repeat of this line Eric I I don't
think we were wrong to not be that
impressed with all the reasons
approached that game even though it
Altima led to a win Alcantara now up on
the clock by a minute so I really do
feel like that's indicative of the fact
that we were right if if Ollie Ruiz it
doesn't get a victory here I think you
might see a little bit of a change up
because if Alcantara doesn't get under
time pressure then well we like blacks
position but black wasn't playing like
someone who thought they were better in
the position I think that's really
critical to beating fridge fridge is
gonna be a favorite in junior
tournaments for the rest of his junior
career he's got like five years of that
he's gonna be number one number two seed
that these other guys in the field are
gonna have to contest with then and you
have to get through that psychological
playing a favorite to like it's one
thing to have the pressure to win but
it's only going to play the top seeds
and all these guys are built up and
deservingly so and and he's just not
playing right now like like someone who
thinks he could be frozen right and even
if we like the positions it's it's the
time it's the way he's playing like I
saw Daniel do it but Dania was very
confident very fast and it certainly
certainly when you see guys who beat
firoozeh there or not they're not
playing slow they're not they're like
the really good blitz players who just
have that that believes that on a good
day a lot of that is also just trusting
your intuition right those guys that
have that experience and they know that
even if they were to overthink it and
find a better move that may not mean
they're finding a better way to win
right sometimes you find the best move
but if it wasn't a critical moment now
you're under more time pressure right so
it's just it's all that field that you
have you know and your intuition is
stronger the more you're playing in
those formats right experience
playing like lead players I mean it's
not easy Peru is a very strong chess
country but they don't have that I made
tournaments so he gets a lot of is
playing experience online I think but
this is a match format this is a lot
more intense than the video Gujarati top
player from India they're in the twitch
chat who just said he thinks that f6 was
a super ugly move we agree with you and
so would Ben Feingold no one's happy
about that effort moving but we need to
punish it maybe he's gonna play like
maybe six is partly because it takes the
square away from the pieces like so idea
maybe in the long run I'm trying to play
like three at some point turn off lines
for bishops and utilize light screws but
this is another approach so what's the
plan with that finding this is obviously
super committal on whites part now we're
seeing a full positional approach here
this doesn't yeah doesn't seem like it
punishes the move because I can now
focus on the c-4 by maybe double roots
and yeah I agree with you in fact I was
gonna say that this kind of approach by
white would work Eric right if we if we
gave white an extra move and that night
was on something like c3 instead of d2
the night would pop into d5 and you've
got you know more of a bind more oxy
bind style but here the the knight is
not in an ideal place to access blacks
weaknesses mm-hmm and and if anything
blacks night is going to be coming to c5
so again I mean if he stays up on time
we've really liked Martinez Alcantara
positions as black in this match if
you're just joining us I know he's down
to oh but this is his opportunity to
strike and keep things close here in the
five-minute portion you know no problem
this position here it might be sort of
see we spend was like 90 and they're not
bad moves and maybe good news but he has
to also be willing to plane was like
aged six and just ruin a move when he
just doesn't have a clear solution i
when you're up on the clock we find the
best maneuver you're saying yeah okay
well but he's but he's in he's in ok
shape here okay Bishop f1 this is an
interesting move you see this battery
which is it's common in a Sicilian to
try to expose blacks overextended Queen
side pawns and questions 98 because no
96 he's just gonna take on b5 take on a6
and just challenging just gonna go win
upon ya this will move by black like
this might be for well then your net
move is fairly useless because one of
the ideas was to bring the net to p4 oh
wow look at this room he's gonna play
Knight before going for it okay so this
is he's gonna win the a two pawns and
this is by a fork on c3 everybody look
at this whether the Queen goes to e2 or
b5 the idea of Martinez Alcantar is to
take this pawn and then land a knight on
c3 we're probably that you're you're
you're delivering a four key mode
whether white likes it or not because
there's just too many pieces for sure
and yeah I like this I mean even if it
doesn't work I like it
now it's easy for me to go crazy with
someone else's pieces but to be fair I
do it with my own as well so that's
clear so it's about accepting that
playing yet practically I think he's
just gonna play Knight C no you can't
play 90 for cos e for saying that's a
bit of a problem you can't just let
things it's not just the material it's
that ephors loose the Queen runs out of
squares
maybe Queen a5 gonna happen anyway and
then push the debug okay this is gonna
be exciting we're gonna have to pass
pawns versus an extra exchange for black
but I liked your point Eric that it's
not just that the rook is falling it's
also the activity black is getting the
axis on the C file the fact that the e4
pawn is sort of spied here by black
maybe even d5
I've got a feeling especially looking at
the clock that this is alcantara game to
get you got to take the exchange and
then just bust things open and go for
the king
you play well and you get a position
like this you know you have to convert
this very accurately right as long as
connected past ponds are coming very
quickly and firuzan even when he's down
he forces you to play a lot of the best
moves to prime yeah this is uh we see
both players zoned in they're focused
because you're you're okay losing
material I'm just pushing my beep on you
take on e4 I play Bishop g2 you take my
route I take it back you've got two
bishops on e7 f7 which while they're
solid they're certainly not stopping
these these right you take and then I
play d5 I push him push him baby b5 and
I guess I'm just too slow because what
if I play d4 Bishop f2 rook c1 I'm just
I guess I'm just too slow cuz these
double pass pawns are just wins who's
gonna find that extracted the best from
from what was a challenging position
that's one of those things that we've
noticed about him since he was a very
young plant mean you you've been
following him like I have since he was
active on chest comm what at age 11 12
and and this and and one thing that you
notice is very it's almost Hikaru s that
even when he blunders he makes it as
tricky as possible for you to find the
right path I think he's more special
than some other parties that come up as
that he's trying to round out his
strategical and positional game but his
fighting abilities are exceptional and
that's gonna blow to well open source
tournaments not all formats a lot of a
lot of different formats where it's good
to not be always just that solid guy
shoutout to Z the Xena bug us who says
what a peeps more great chess coverage
thanks dudes thank you
all right rooks III splayed the bishop
on III has to make a decision but but
now how do we deal with all these
pastors okay I do like this I like the
fact that there's a more of a chance
that someone blunders with an open King
and time scrambles but d5 and n c3 well
I was just clear enough b5 right away
okay he's gonna get the Queen's off the
board yes he's gonna say these bonds are
gonna win ce7 might be interesting
rook d7 even even b6 does he have time
b1 okay gentles settles not just winning
his rook back right not too bad to
settle on that at least to temporarily
hold the pawn is stuck here comes rook
e8 followed by Bishop c5 it's Red Rover
Wow
a frustrating finish there for Martinez
Alcantara in a frustrating situation in
the match right now down three oh and
and for the first time we're already
talking about hey like how do you handle
yourself against Ali Riza firoozeh
in this situation he's just so good you
know he lost the exchanges they're
pretty nice I was very pleased gonna
push his pawns then then Martinez
Alcantara took around a minute didn't
really find anything used but that
minute is where I like Holly res is
building his confidence realizing that
hey actually I have a good position I
put on some comfortable and the Resta
game you played very comfortably before
that
you could debate that he wasn't playing
so well but when he smells blood
he absolutely goes for it and and that
was that was where I think he was
feeling like oh I thought it doesn't
know how to deal with these pawns and he
said to me except our bows and the rest
of the game sort of cleared itself it
did sort of play itself from White's
perspective there was if you were to
call it that's what would happen like
bicycle on time doesn't know how to
solve the pawns who doesn't and just
gonna panic I didn't have a thing for
black but certainly yeah and it's been
it's been a tough day right now for
Martinez Alcantara but the day is still
young for the nearly 2,000 of you with
us and it has us talking about our daily
question again remind you of the
storyline of a lot of the junior
speeches championship brought to you by
chess kid is going to be which of these
chess kids maybe has the best chance to
become a future world chess champion so
if you haven't seen it use the hashtag
speed chess give us your opinion on
twitch or on Twitter and let us know we
may we may read your question on the
show today and and and shout out maybe
even some diamond membership so but this
is the kind of this is maybe this is a
good good reason we asked that question
today because Olly Olly Reza is um this
kid is this kid is special and right now
Martinez Alcantara just has to hope to
contain him and keep this thing close as
they as the match moves on following the
players progress the last time I had
this feeling would have been 15 years
ago with my keeper Nakamura around the
same like at least for online chess you
talk about prodigies but they're like
classical just by design Reza is the
strongest like you know online player
coming up then I've never seen actually
because he kernel was actually at 16 he
was just a beast already and I was
already known but this this this is this
is another feeling now we have a mix up
here in game 2 the first time that
Martinez Alcantara had white we had a
Spanish if you're just joining us now
we're now we're in in English we'll back
this thing up and take you through the
opening that we just had there and
in English transposing into some sort of
double fee and keto Slav and ultimately
arriving it sort of a sort of an obscure
kind of unique position here if this
could have come from a ready could have
come from even a Karel con in some ways
I don't even know so we're at weird
position I think the biggest thing for
Alcon for Martinez Alcantara is going to
be time right now and right now dealing
with the d3 square do you have to settle
on a move like 91 because after in the
future you're gonna play through anyways
and then you bring the knight to d3
where has covers both be 5 and c5 which
are squares you'd love to put your
pieces on ok anyone opens up your bishop
so that's someone that should be played
very quickly in future with this sort of
opening I music this is a very solid
opening but certainly not one way is
challenging black to us or white too
much right away it's an opportunity for
for Martinez all concerning to build up
a good position because this yeah an
opening not black players and it's like
why you're gonna get a bit of a space
advantage a bit of an edge that's what
you do with it but it's the balls in
your court
yeah like that and the Rema nuvaring the
knight on d3 as you highlight it holds
some some critical squares in the
structure for black e5 and c5 and so ok
this is one where we we do think that
white has what has done fine in the
first stage of things some of you saw
that stat line they're wondering what
the most dominant we have never had a
1000 or the quote-unquote I guess you
would call a chess chess urban
dictionary of adoption we have never had
that in any speeches championship match
or format ever even even matches of what
you would consider heavy heavy favorites
such as guys like Magnus Carlsen versus
taker on Petrosian or hey Cara Nakamura
versus Joey fawn so we've never seen the
the urban the urban legend happen I
don't I don't think it's gonna happen
today either but anyway just fun fact
for those of you talking about it in
chat ICU because he wants to do it he
will tell you in chat he will try to
demoralize you he wants without saying
things you shouldn't say
how how much how much trash talk has
been thrown down between you and Ollie
Reza because I find it I find it
enjoyable it's refreshing to have chess
players express emotions when they lose
when they win things like that so I but
he talks every single time he he doesn't
mind talking to you Carlo fedosya I saw
him when they are playing those guys are
beating Daniel he doesn't doesn't matter
who it is what they're reading is he use
it as a challenge and someone has to
take down and you'll fertilize it he'll
play a hundred games 200 games however
long it takes but pretty much there's a
charter maybe in his house or a mental
chart yeah if you peel back those
curtains that are doing some talking
themselves right now there's a wall with
all of your faces on it and you know the
little markers of of how he's done yeah
stop there
still staying we didn't have Sun and a
half which I hardly ever see yeah and
that shows you right it's such a such a
rare thing so this has turned into an
obscure kind of stone wall here Erik or
black having f5 is there an outside
chance the black goes full mating net
here with g5 and f4 or is the queenside
falling too fast because is falling on
the queenside so usually it's but just
by just by you know necessity otherwise
the other perspective is will foucha
possibly try to defend the e5 pawn and
knowing him I'm probably gonna say no
he's much more challenging than that
because Queen d8 writing you play Queen
the heir to the how do you defend if I
win da I think that's just a temporary
move because then black oh I can play c5
96 and probably win the pawn back so I
expect them to attack maybe you play
Queen d2 provoke c5 and say that that
closes down the Queen side I'm gonna
lose a if I pawn in the long run but by
closing down the Queen's that maybe I
could
this attack some sort of aggressive he
does not like the passively defend and
he's not particularly good at it which
is the time it works I like this move
Bishop of three because he's sort of
recognizing hey blacks Queen site isn't
going anywhere right it's broken so let
me make sure I don't get mated and then
I can pick off that pawn later you you
you buying that that this this idea of
eliminating the attack is a good one
here I like what White's doing White's
doing but he just has to keep keep it up
for a whole game that's what we haven't
seen yet we've been happy with with
pockets of of whites player Martinez
he's he's certainly playing some
positions very very well but at some
point he loses the plot and right now
this is a critical position this is
where we'll see if he has what it takes
to score some wins against Persia
because King Grandmaster username para
moth who of course is para mug Sulu
actually the reigning world junior
champion and countryman from Iran of
Allah Reza ferocious so if you didn't
know how strong chess was in Iran we
actually have two of them playing in the
juniors features championship will
actually give an impromptu kind of
update for those of you who follow in
mark your calendars early we actually
are rescheduling the para mug Zulu match
when the world junior champion will make
his debut here he will be traveling so
his matches now on June second not June
third I believe we're not June 5th well
we'll bring an update to you on that
very very shortly in regards having it
officially in writing but yeah you can
mark your calendars that the world
junior champion in and Iranian
countrymen of kirusha will be playing on
June second versus Moroni the young
Italian so anyway shout-out to para moth
who's hanging out in the chest TV chat
with our members but objectively the
Nano six is a poor piece he put the
Queen og to 2096 d5 pawn he went for
Queen each one I was a meeting attempts
but I
with king of one that's saying there's
no mail at all here how do you deal with
it from the opening down to 30 seconds
rip Age 2 threatens me on F to the Queen
Baek it's too far and if Queen g1 those
were kids when pinning the Queen I don't
I don't see how he stops it because then
mate what there should be one or
something your queen has the squares
after acacia see yeah I mean I was with
you I was just about to highlight how
good time management by Martinez
Alcantara again you highlighted the
night on a6 was bad all you had to do
was survive the h-file
unfortunately all whites pieces on 8th
for c1 c3 they just do nothing to stop
the infiltration of blacks pieces on the
Kings side so it's just the one way one
way result here wow this is just six
which is gonna be made on the board and
Martinez o-tar gives a small smile
they're a little bit of a nod and that's
a that's a tough moment right there and
a tough sign of things to come I have to
correct myself Erik apparently we have
had 110 Oh or as we said the the urban
urban legend the the pop culture for
those who speak twitch chests the an
adoption happened in the 3-1 portion
between acara Nakamura and holy fun we
have never seen it we've never seen a
shutout in either the 5-1 or the 1-1 I
don't think but we have had a 1000
performance in 2/3 one portion by
knocking moreover Yvonne in the first
round of the SEC last year goes behind
the scenes they got to keep me in check
Danny puts his foot in his mouth and
then they correct him it's a whole fun
thing we do around here
so wow that's not on Carlos territory
just the second guy
yeah the curtains the curtains are are
hiding his real intentions there for ali
reza all right well again if you're just
joining us it's still we still have a
lot of chess ahead of course right now
we see a 4o deficit for martinez
Alcantar but Eric and I have both been
complimentary of the positions he's
getting here as black it's just it's
been clock management and just having
winning all the scrambles we can
actually just like we kind of smelt the
red earlier we're like is he gonna he
gonna go for g5 go for the Queen
whatever and then and he just well as
you said he kind of had you but he also
did it with ruthless accuracy the world
junior champion para mom is saying
anybody can ask him any questions they
wanted the chest TV chat so he's hanging
out ask questions to the reigning world
junior champion at chest comm TV in the
chat if you want right now so all right
well he's playing this one a little more
aggressive than last time vinegar Zarate
who was in the twitch chat eric was very
critical of the approach to meet f4 with
f6 i think we agreed here the night
comes to f6 this is a little more night
or style as as risky as this is now you
can take on e 2 again you have to get d5
but he's been weighing the law which is
what counts but I know for nano players
you're getting especially when the pawns
are and he throw a 5 as you said do play
for deeper at some point you can
probably maximize your position first oh
wow
he plays he four just right away and
she's just
come again she's counting on the bishop
here on the queenside wants to use the B
file and the rooks but black should not
be upset it's not it's not even he's not
even putting like practical pressures
why it's often black tries to attack in
these positions and somewhere things go
if something goes wrong and through
capitalizes but but if it was not
playing aggressively and usually why do
the heavy lifting I was just gonna say
if you go all-in now on the C pawn you
can't play Bishop of one like he did in
the previous game cuz e4 falls so all
the res applies she for but look how
fast he's playing is this is this the
gay Martinez Alcantara gets on the board
he plays h6 instantly again I don't buy
the mating net from white if all the
pieces come off the board I like this
move Knight h7 though it hits h4 over
protects g5 and again this this c4 pawn
is going nowhere White has no time to
play both white needs Bhishma f1 and a
move like Bishop f2 to guard h4 these
games just because White's expanded a
lot but there's pieces of those let's
show the trick that was on the board if
black had taken C for everybody
Ali Reza had to had set up a little bit
of a skewer emote there you didn't know
we have the skewer emote use it that's a
tactic and that would have that would
have been bad so Martinez Alcantara
doesn't blend her instead he plays a
move that makes all the residues head
I'm liking I'm liking blacks chances
here look how focused he is solid
supporting an h4 saying one central
falls g5 is the next square that block
is gonna take advantage of and while all
this is happening you have a horrible
Disher Bungie to just block White's on
bonds so you're gonna be down
internalize and
positionally in business and down a
minute left on the clock
when working your ass yeah there's no
like attack here for why there's no way
for you to planner it's a few just like
you know self-inflicted White's not
putting any pressure on that's a great
move though right there by firoozeh
because I think from a practical point
of view you just didn't want to allow
him to take h4m when the pawn cleanly
and that's as Eric said it's one of the
things that all the resident if things
don't don't work out perfectly he finds
a way to mix it up Queen d7 don't worry
about it right rikiei your bond c4 still
hanging g5 looks great for should he
have taken c4 on the last move yeah it's
a second pawn it also gets the C file I
wonder if he got a little bit too solid
but you you've been saying that even
when he's better he's not playing like
he's winning in some cases so we'll see
if he can if getting a win on the board
fixes that sort of psychological issue
that Martinez Alcantar has had but if he
doesn't get this one after he just had a
chance to take on c4 cleanly I'm gonna
I'm gonna come back to questioning this
moment here that's a sign of just lack
of confidence for for black to spawn
structure and just by taking on d3 it's
just like yeah that's a great move any
fine sets thinking in his head
is very very resourceful just as hard to
you know one thing dishes aren't that
dynamic here right the digital g2 just
simply doesn't have like a way to be
tricky
the bishop one has to is fairly
predictable so the ability for black - a
trick to get tricked here is a little
lower than than some other positions
with maybe two way attacking Knights
hopping around this shouldnít position
where you are clear in your objective is
black and yeah John Wick's no John wick
style don't hesitate right they took
your dog dude Martinez Alcantara needs
to start playing like you know so how do
you do it do you go over the night from
o6u you like the pressure on e4 but
again I'm I'm just been thinking about
you a lot of the night you bring your
net out for maybe six and it's going to
bring thing I like it but he didn't see
it he and now he's fixing the structures
fixing the structure yes this is another
winning position more than this to try
to turn off the dark positions that's a
little harder he missed taking the pawn
and he missed d5 and like I said I keep
coming back to your sort of observation
of the psychology of just you have to
play like you know you're gonna win and
right now I have a sense the advantages
not nearly as big as it could have been
for black Samara I assume you'd like to
move is Knight to d7 the blade - at age
4 and trying to corral the dark for
vision
yeah and just you know towards pure in
game takes me Portland what am I missing
there takes
yet 94 Bishop g2 some sort of okay he
was going for some sort of tactics and
fidgety - okay okay
so black believes him and just puts the
rook back that's that's very and even
now you can play for 1994 I was thinking
97 and your plan of issue 84 but this is
even better
no I want to yeah Martinez Alcantara
bishop he knows this one is close here
comes the Queen in don't bring it in now
but 93 check first and then Queen g5
this just this happens need lights out
there will be no adoption maybe we can
tell Martinez Alcantara to shake his to
campaign matumbo finger after this and
say no adoptions in my house you just
want to secure that way
he wants it you gotta get it though now
he's thinking of all the different way
so it was a night check in the night
f-for looks for you to me in Queen in
2004 threatens Queen h1 it threatens
Queen Chi - it's over 94 he finds 93
also with queen h1 and queen f1 is that
made it is and the decay and now I'm
sort of think that you're right about
the match strategy that you know Ali
Reza firoozeh played that one out not
just to avoid matumbo in the chat but
also can really milk it on the clock
right he's what I know what's going on
here okay he all he did was get on the
board and now and now we've got a lot
more time off of the five-minute portion
because he could have resigned that one
a long time ago down to pawns and we got
both sides on the scoreboard now and
firoozeh is not happy yep she is happy
I've never met a more confident sugar
Clare than bruiser
but as you said he's confident but he
also is you know he's uh he's a creature
of passion and emotion right he loves he
loves to mix it up talk a little talk a
little trash we see those heads there on
the odds to win the match chart finally
move a positive direction for Martinez
Alcantara that so those who love our
little emote emote heads stat line there
I love that right now we've got we've
got kind of a path of
what we predicted we also have a new
club that I don't know if smarter chess
is listening where stat stat chest at
nerds can can get involved in discuss
and debate all the different ways that
we can use math to predict and and maybe
assess outcomes of matches like this so
a lot of the stats in that club as I
understand we're very similar people
doing their own predictions to
complement smarter chesses match
predictions but anyway right now is
Martinez Alcantara is on the board Eric
there shall be no adoption no a long
time chess table in there and it today
nothing feels better than being trolled
by Tony Hsieh exactly for me like he's
actually one of my favorite rollers on
on chess I don't mean in a bad way tell
me you know who you are it's it's the
the smart way the smart way that happens
but all right so d4 is played and we've
got it we've got a very common
structural imbalance of what you would
see in a Spanish game and we see that
Martinez Alcantara comes back to that
so for keeping track everybody we saw a
Spanish that we saw in English and now
we see Joseph em coming back to the
Spanish but okay even though the
structure is typical for white I feel
like all the Reza is also recovering
here look at the clock Eric and and look
at blacks position very comfortable if
you commit to the space which is what I
just did then block is gonna commit to
the kingside and at some points good
prepared so it's a bit of a race against
the clock here because at the same time
white could take 1 b5 may be played
before and liquidate a lot on the
queenside over there right but he really
tries to maximize that brace himself or
refuses uh you know f5 metaphor and the
King started mission so talk about the
pawns I know this is some slightly more
advanced stuff
I mean this is me trying to learn from
Grand Master Eric Hansen I mean cuz you
know you play d5 you're breaking the
tension as white and you're you're not
maintaining what is normally required
like you said to keep black from going
for these sort of pollen storms with f5
and f4 and but what is it about the the
structure that indicates to white that
the timing works for this is it exactly
what you said the threat of a B 5 and
then B 4 was coming and so black just
doesn't have the time to focus on the
kingside or what is it about this
position that indicates that d5 is is
the right time for white well sometimes
you play d5 because you feel like
there's too much pressure on d4 on your
own lands there in this case it's also
that f5 smart to achieve because after
f5 f5 takes some moves because you do
the calculations after a 5 what can take
on f5
yeah play take on e5 and the Queen on d1
hits this night on e h5 assuming the
black recaptures upon so tactically
sometimes white actually encourages
black to play out 5 because it also
gives white some targets right okay that
makes sense and I was highlighting that
now black is switching over to the Queen
side has prevented white from the plan
you discussed with a B and then B 4 but
no I still feel like you know black
heads looks just comfortable I guess
from how I normally assess the the space
and the pawn structure in a Lopez and I
think at some point we're probably gonna
see the Black Knight from h5 come in to
f4 and even be willing to break the
structure to open up the dark square
Bishop that's a very that's a little
more risky force night at 4 pretty much
plan to take I mean to me that seems
like a good sign for Martinez Alcantara
if you can get away which he for and
sort of call the bluff of the idea I was
highlighting I mean are we are we in
store for something like King g2 and
then g5 and then this is the kind of
Lopez attack that Bobby Fischer would
love if he was playing white right this
is true
he's confident too plain was a Jeep or
maybe that's a pretty good sign he's not
really afraid of giving through
potential targets because the upside
there is that you could have a very very
good King side attack as you pointed out
kingi to maybe bring the truck to h1
that's some point you're gonna break the
g5 that's a carp off of Bishop e7 gonna
force them I don't even know that I like
it but you know like yeah Queen each is
a flexible move because it prepares like
you said we have the King set idea but
you also have the idea of the other were
coming to a1 and doubling if need be and
yeah and and I think I think like you
said I think g5 is coming at some point
and if the h-file opens up this has
become a slightly odd position where I
feel like all the reds and let the
middle game slip a little bit it's very
complicated and you could plan a date
for now and then you know White has to
play like this Bishop e3 and you slow
core pieces on the board we still have I
mean a lot of a lot of different ways
that this game can go I think he might
be preparing 97 no but any sevens for f5
otherwise it's not that good yeah I
think down to the wire there's neither
side wants to give up something here
really lets his emotions show when he's
surprised by a move no it's there and
says all right all right 94 I guess I
didn't really see that coming and
actually the more I look at it the more
I really like 984 by Olly Reza look at
look at how it points out the
awkwardness of the Queen and Bishop kind
of married to each other now because if
this trade happens everyone the rooks
are forever cut off from protecting the
priest and the Queen is stuck with the
duty I actually I actually really like
that a4 I mean I think has a great
position for kind of play so even though
white is trying to grab more space as a
player see a long time that's harder to
maintain
sorry to keep keep intact and we're
suggesting now there's no threat right
now like you're not going to lose that
Bishop on a seven but yeah why don't
they need to play gmod and do something
but but now but now h5 comes I mean I
feel like chief I was wait to take my
bishop gets into the game there's
targets now that's it what's not gonna
take me six maybe I play f6 and I file
yeah to attract well now you have a
threat no okay now this is this is
actually like okay so this makes sense
you're trying to hit c4 but yeah I mean
so you're you're looking at queen bee
894 Bishop e5 and saying white just has
too many pieces on free but it's still
terracotta everywhere now it's the piece
that's seconds about to get dropped
Martinez Alcantara has got full tilt
he's got a full emery Tate the late and
great put a knight on f5 and hope for me
I didn't mean for all that cheer with
Bishop a7 we're again even though that
was interesting it kind of felt like it
was it was headed the wrong way and the
moment Knight g8 was played all he
resident was setting up two things
taking away the power of g5 everyone cuz
it was no longer a double attack and
preparing this move Knight a4 now that
g5 was no longer a threat and I just
don't think Alcantara saw that coming
with the move Queen III not if for 20
hours of blunder so perhaps white needed
to trade on see
five back in this moment here I think
that was the critical moment of the game
this is completely losing unfortunately
you've lost your light squared bishop
and you've lost a piece you know your
looks aren't involved and the food's
gonna keep you cool head here
complimentary of his countrymen saying
that a4 was a great move also answering
a ton of questions people asking how to
get better talking about what to do with
tactics and balancing knowing sharp
opening so real advice he's getting a
lot of chess absolutely any questions so
future superpower and there are you just
a strong contender but it's like the
growth is insane yeah yeah it's the five
one-time control and ali reza parousia
has a 5-1 lead and III don't know what
else to say besides it's it is iran all
day right now we got para mug subbu this
should be a new feature of the junior
speeches championship have a different
chest kid in the chat given advice but
cuz marks who did this on his own and
he's uh answering questions so um thank
you to everyone who's here regardless of
where you may be enjoying the show from
twitch or chest comm TV we appreciate it
answering questions I think it's it's
more interesting for just fans to follow
the juniors because if you actually end
up becoming a fan one of the players or
learning more about them that's
something you can fall for a long time
right you know I mean like let's say you
get into gesso on be kind of crammed
well he just retired unfortunately but
these guys it's like bowling draft picks
falling guys like it's like there's a
you're gonna get a real serious return
this you become a fan of Arusha he's
playing all the time or nights or
or Martinez here these guys you'll have
a whole career absolutely we also have
the women's speech has championship to
look forward to remember that tomorrow's
matchup is the first one of really the
the bracket kicking off right we've got
Katharina log note-taking on are our
winner of the WS CC qualifier from
almost two weeks ago
SOPA go a bit much really along with
honor Rudolf will have the call so join
us tomorrow at 9:00 a.m. Pacific
Standard Time
whatever that is CET GCT don't yell at
me all right I know Global Times but I'm
not gonna talk I'm not even gonna do
that not gonna dance for you monkey but
whatever time zone that is for you be
here and watch the women's speeches
championship kick off tomorrow that's
only eight players Eric so eight of the
world's top female chess players but for
the same amount of prize money so even
bigger prizes for the ladies honestly
I'm a little jelly what's that purple
looks so good on the blue like who did
that a designer just so good it's just
you know how I feel about purple and
blue alright well we've got a shake-up
an English attack with a bishop on hu
Eric this is more my style right here in
English attack absolutely I suppose as
well by the way I think he's a great a
great attacking player and the positions
that he was playing as weddings and
ivory but I think you just playing
poorly pity those are just bad positions
and I think we finally like last skiing
Perugia was just playing on the back
foot the entire game yeah and doesn't
matter just he's probably thinking
himself why am I even allowing this
thinking I must have misplaced it to
actually stop the entire like 10k you
and I've been calling that since Game
one if you're just joining us everyone
Game one of the match was kind of an
awkward I don't say dubious but not good
night or for firoozeh and then Game
three was the same but it took all the
way to Game five from Martinez Alcantara
to finally score in that night off and
so as Eric said all the resin it up but
that's the sign of a great player right
I mean I kind of liked that he sticks
with something until he loses with it I
feel like I feel like just from a
practical match strategy it makes sense
you make them prove it and
then and then you'll lose it well you
can also really frustrate people when
you you are hitting from west positions
and they know it and you know it just by
saying hey I don't mind taking worse
positions August I'll play so so yeah he
he gave it a good run and now we have a
almost like a French like structure
right that is a little transposed to
definitely French structure but pieces
are different squares then slightly more
active than you might normally get a
French shout out to honor Rudolf for a
much better French than sometimes she
would get but you know what you know
what we have to say this was a great
answer in the interviews that we gave
the players and I think it's appropriate
for the match here Eric that okay yes we
asked these young guys lots of questions
but when we asked Jose Martinez
Alcantara what the best advice was he
ever had from a chess coach and his
coach told him that if there's still
room to struggle you have to play on
right and what do you think of that just
from a psychological from a mindset if
you were giving advice to juniors as a
chess coach what is that what does that
mindset say to you about Alcantara you
know the most famous player ever from
from Peru what I noticed about playing
all the Peruvians was they had
tremendous fighting spirit and that was
something that it's not a big focus on
theory not a big focus on necessarily
like books and why not but if there's a
fight you you put in full effort from
start to finish and it's easier said
than done
right right I mean just a second such a
psychological getting what it really
means is psychologically when there's a
struggle you keep fighting right because
that's the first battle to actually get
yourself to keep keep trying to find the
best news when when you feel like you're
about to lose and then once you get past
that then you actually the actual muscle
work but yeah I mean yeah I think I
think from playing him and seeing some
of his results he didn't have like a ton
of coaches growing up didn't have a ton
of resources the guy maximized and he
works for the heart in his positions and
we'll see if that might probably a lot
of people watching have not heard of
Martinez Alcantara much right but he's
been a world champ
and that says a lot and he's no and he's
still one of the top shooters in the
world I mean despite maybe not having
the presence or reputation that all the
rezidentura does here on chess calm but
great great advice there if you're
tuning is a chess parent or chefs kid
and hopefully advice that Martinez
alcantara can give himself John wick was
not for me don't know the twitch chat
with nonsense this Canadian Canadians
have a lot of fighting spirit - I mean I
would say that they do yeah we have to
compensate for a lack of culture and the
the the chess culture stigmas are kind
of real it's actually a show we should
do separately cuz I think you and I've
talked about that that different chest
cultures do sort of cultivate different
personality traits or I mean jokes aside
right I think that you said that a lot
of the Peruvians have a fighting spirit
that I think is actually something that
makes them very tricky they're often
very resourceful players right I mean
and and I think that when you play them
over the board you have to be prepared
for the fact that they are not going
down without a fight and I think that
Martinez Alcantara is gonna do that
today look at this he's up he's up a
minute on the clock and again he's
better as black Eric he's been better as
black all day he just hasn't converted
[Music]
and he nice night and he's putting
that's both aggressive and preparing to
be defensive I'm anticipating he'll
probably just take a five here sometimes
you put a piece like Queen d7 Queenie
six right you know you six blocks the
pawn from pushing these eggs and opening
up the darks right vision also house
defend against the king
ali reza is like a piece of way from a
puzzle rush made if you take a five
there's not time to sack on h6 and blow
up in the bishop here there's just not a
big of a g6 and take a five yes because
it looks like i just don't i slowly the
works but i didn't give it enough
thought at first
like right now g6 he's gonna take on
that five no doubt he's gonna take on a
5 mm you have fallen speeds when a jeep
Borya not I I love it Queen g4 with a
threat of East 6 and Bob's your uncle
and h8 over here this is this is better
we've seen everyone without contour
Martinez Alcantara holding his own the
first stage the transfer in the middle
game even a little bit of an edge on the
clock but but now the time patrols gonna
be real and Purusha is gonna make it as
messy as possible I think I'm with you
from a practical point of view I mean so
you know what was what was the solution
we might as well see anything else
that's a good point looking over of
e6000
and and try to cause it longer you know
but ok if this if this converts as well
into a potential point here for Martinez
Alcantara which right now I mean this
looks good he I think he can take a
second pawn he's got a very good knight
on e4
I mean c2 so hanging everything
I like putting like okay so Queen d7 you
run into crazy double pin let me show
there be six Eric is pointing out that
we have made on f8 and made on g7 f6 you
one thing you want to do is black here
is get your work on b5 into the game
because you just simply don't want to
play the rest of the game right it's not
gonna help especially when it comes to
defending so watch out for that
what spikes causing problems just being
annoying seconds now both sides under
time pressure this is gonna be a
scramble he takes the wings off the
board he's gonna put the knight on f3
he's gonna go for the C to pawn
regardless but you highlighted would be
awkward Eric and look at it there you go
[Music]
he's gonna make this messy get the King
off the bank no no time living off the
increment ollie rez
is the pin is no telling your daddy oh
my gosh
all the rest flagged him all that is
painful that was a game white had no
business winning oh he had no business
winning that game something like b3
Jeffery black was still winning on King
b3 but even a move like 96 is actually
very very clean because you force this
trade for the rook on d4 and then I
think the F pawn just becomes a girl on
f1 right delivery room yeah I mean in
rook f7 is met by Knight f3 so to be
clear everybody that that even that
final position was still winning for
Martinez Alcantara even if he missed
something earlier but ali reza showing
the blitz and bullet prowess as Eric
said King to be free it's just an
annoying move to face Knight b5 also
does the same trick by the way so both
night b5 and ninety-six would have been
winning for Martinez Alcantara but that
is just a heartbreaker and a unfortunate
probably sign of things to come with
Ollie resident now with a 6-1 lead and
only 7 minutes to go in the 5-1 portion
yeah dude that was nuts that was that
was a heartbreaker if you're in the if
you're in the camp of the Peruvian here
just let food survive you know I mean
even getting to that stage right he got
his plan he took the 86 bond
and kept himself in the game long enough
that it turned into just like a time
scramble and I think everyone would
consider them a pretty strong favorite
time sometimes in hindsight you look at
those big moments and say oh it was just
that blunder was just the time scramble
but like you said it was the fact that
Martina's Alcantara has been winning for
the last 25 moves right and easily when
you don't put you can lose games
sometimes by not winning them yeah and
that's an example of that right not
being confident or or whatever it is
quick enough or trusting you know we use
whatever you want to do to describe why
Martinez Alcantar didn't put it away but
like you said if you put firoozeh in a
position to swindle you guess what he's
gonna do wowzers wowzers well we have
six minutes left here in the five minute
portion if you're just tuning in thanks
for being here this is the junior
speeches championship brought to you by
chess kid calm with me the one and only
mr. chess bra himself grandmaster Eric
Hanson and at a whole lot of you with us
in chat and everywhere some thanks for
being here we have a world junior
champion countryman Parma muck Sulu
hanging out in the chess TV chat
answering questions with members we've
got somebody of the same level chess
wise Tommy fook and she'll be in the
twitch chat rightz so we've got you know
choose your choose your choose your chat
we've got amazing mods thank you to
chess Bay and I think I saw NJ Craig
here and all the help we have supporting
the channel thank you for being here
everybody know it's Friday night it's
the protesting summer series you know
you've never chosen twitch over over a
lady friend right I did that I would I
think I would for making this when I did
it for omegas once he wanted to play I
told my wife it was so funny was a
weekend because I got a mobile alert
that you were playing Magnus and I was
like honey
go right now Eric is throwing the 94 was
played everyone by the way of fun tactic
just to show that if white had taken on
g7 black has this plan Queen b6 check in
her MS o and then all kinds of nastiness
there so that was why the g7 bishop was
not taken and instead Bishop a6 was
played by Martinez Alcantara but that's
just another nasty swindle by the young
Iranian I had a funny situation where it
did ask why are you explain the seeker
guy because then you're always in the
bathroom and I just and it was like like
I was like laid and like tilted and I
was like I mean that's just I I can't
explain it sometimes you know why I why
I do it it's like what just don't put
your car yeah
just don't you know it's so funny
because I would I would also tell my
wife that back when I played I know what
I would be like I have to stop like
ending my day by trying to play a half a
bullet you know yeah when you're
exhausted it's just like it just you
sends you home on tilt and you know
alright Bishop III played a nice idea
trying to do London Queen from the d4
square and honestly that's a really
irritating tactic we can see that
Martinez Alcantar a little frustrated
because isn't Queen d2 met by rook c2
[Music]
you know Queen d2 Brooksie - Queen d3
that's that's the approach but he didn't
he play you know okay that makes sense
I like you're looking to trade off the
darks provisions which is a favorable
trade for white Brooks agency is being
relying on tactics in this particular
positions that hold on and I think
he's running out right now I don't see
any more fuel to throw in I mean if
you're just joining seven we've seen
games where Martinez Alcantara was
better and potentially winning like the
like the game we had right before this
so I guess if you're in Mart if you're
in his corner as a coach you're saying
hey look you've had chances you've got
to get confident you know remember
remember to trust yourself play quickly
and and that's how you keep yourself
focused because the truth is you don't
need anything if you're in ferruginous
corner besides hey dude you're up 6:1
and you're getting to a faster time when
she lets just keep doing your thing so I
don't know if I'm if I'm the coach for
the chess kid that is Martinez Alcantara
I just want to get him focus on the
positive which is that you've had some
games where you were better out of the
opening and you've just got to play more
confident and speed up so if he gets
actually if firoozeh resigns somehow he
would actually give one more 5min again
we still have a minute and a half
officially and all games started before
the segment clock ends everyone will
always count toward the score that I
think I think he's aware of that I think
he's just gonna get rid of the 5 minute
portion even if he loses this one
because you almost never ever give up
the exchange right whatever just trade
down see ya I think Bishop CA now you
can't take g3 because of Bishop c4 and
on rook c8 then just just take the
knight take g4 Queen g3 rookie three and
afterward see you play Knight H 1 I know
that looks ridiculous Byron over the
night on Essex goes he settles on just
taking g4 first ok but now he can take
ca
or play rookie isn't this your variation
you take on seed and play wiki three and
your upper four
yeah I see the rooks you won but I don't
think there's a perpetual where Eric and
I are looking at this line everyone
takes takes here queen of four takes b3
rook c1 and i just because queen III
just make it simple we should be
resigned time because now everyone this
clean g4 doesn't work when you take b3
you guard c2 and if you force the
exchange as much as you wish you won
more material there should be a very
easy one so we need three looks like
should do the trick like if he tries to
take okay finally he settles but if he
if he had if he had taken a ton of time
trying to justify Brooke III everyone
that would have been worthy of our
criticism because it's just unnecessary
and in blitz games like this having a
clear plan is just as important as
whether or not it's the best plan
oftentimes and and the fact that you can
do it quickly so I just think you might
be right I think firoozeh was kind of
caught napping in this one maybe just
kind of throw and thrown in a kind of a
dud a bad egg here given that he's been
up so much but okay I mean Torres corner
you get him to focus on the positive and
maybe he can make it close at the blitz
portion before the bullet comes yeah
should be more than I mean this is 15
seconds but you have the implement you
have to convert on this no excuses no
excuses gonna try but in time scramble
here we could we could be about to see a
blunder on as far as okay this was a
good idea doubling rooks you know but
it's not enough time you could have just
taken g7 at Bishop d5 that was a bluff
and just absolutely even though that's
actually our first draw of the
five-minute portion which by the way is
I don't know what the stats are on that
but we don't often have eight games
played and only one peaceful one so that
was a super exciting way unfortunately
for Martinez Alcantara to bring this
portion to a close because you could I
mean you could easily make this make
this a 5-3 score which would be closer
to what our prediction was there were a
couple games that just were definitely
Martinez Alcantar is to win but the
scoreboard speaks what it does for a
reason ali reza for lucia proven why
he's one of the favorites in this format
eric we're gonna take a very quick break
the junior speeches championship brought
to you by chess kid comm continues when
we returned don't go anywhere we'll be
right back
[Music]
trés kid is fun jess is great for the
brain it's also fun to play and chess
kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent approved way for your child to
play chess online chess kid is
educational to kids it feels just like
playing the chess is a great way to
learn patience strategy and critical
thinking chess kid features a
comprehensive training program that
guides kids to level up on their way to
mastery
this curriculum is designed to work with
common core standards and global
educational guidelines there are more
than 50,000 chess puzzles and a whole
library of entertaining videos that
teach strategies tactics openings and
end games specifically for kids chess
kid is easy whether you're a parent
helping your child a coach managing
dozens of kids or a school of hundreds
chess kit helps you organize your
students and monitor their progress each
child receives a weekly report card that
shows how many lessons puzzles and games
are completed you can also organize kids
into clubs and send the messages chess
kid is the online home of scholastic
chess for thousands of kids parents
schools and coaches signing up is free
and easier so what are you waiting for
[Music]
how adorable is that Jessica do though
Eric I mean come on that's an adorable
video the chess kid video test kid is
it's just in a cute little pawn right
cute little pond a little bit more
ruthless than all the rest of Arusha I
don't know I mean I don't know what to
say right now if you're Martinez
alcântara scamp what are you doing to
right the ship here in 3-1 besides I
think the biggest thing is just play
with more confidence and play faster
right he's missing some points Dani that
if he played a little faster converted a
little better which is within his
capabilities we'd have a closer match
that I saw somebody in chat say Sherlock
wrench strikes again play faster and
better and that's the key you're right
Sherlock wrench strikes again I mean a
you know thank you
last game of the year Dan you don't know
anything back now well we have the three
minute portion kicking off here this is
the jr. speeches championship brought to
you by chess kid if you're just getting
here we got grandmaster Eric Hanson in
the house ali reza firoozeh Jose
Martinez Alcantara and it's been
exciting it's also been a very lopsided
match right now with one of the
favorites to win the whole thing and and
we'll see if if that changes here in the
three-minute portion so that's all I got
that's all I got now we're back to a
more English attacking style we saw Ali
Reza to this in the last night or game
of the 5-minute but again the problem is
none of the opening this was a winning
game this was a winning position for the
Peruvian right but he couldn't convert
absolutely and in every single yeah
every single game that Martinez
Alcantara has had as black has given him
many opportunities to get the score so
again yeah and really never the issue
this is gonna be really sharp one coming
right out of the gates rook c8 95 you
know the drill
fighting for that c4 square that's what
black goes for a quick inside initiative
white on them in the meantime plays h4
h5 who gets there first but we don't see
there's not doesn't feel like there's a
large strength difference in the opening
and early middle game you know what
afterwards
Perugia just maximizes his opportunities
which is just a trade of a lot of it
speed chess players and and there's been
a lot of fun Bulls from from Martinez
Alcantara
I tend to I can't I know I keep saying
this I've been a broken record liking
Martinez Alcantara Snider versus black
despite the scoreboard but the bishop
this exact type of position is playable
and more of a race for white when the
bishop is on f1 the pawn is back on a2
and and white is a couple moves ahead
the fact that black is already getting
this very natural breakthrough I mean
again I don't you know play chess at the
levels that only Reza Ferruccio does
certainly not online blitz but something
tells me this repertoire that he has as
white against the night or if Eric is
not is not the most worked out part of
his game yet Danny and we're liking
blacks positions I know because we're
bias that these aren't the most
challenging lines
yeah for sure as you're trying to
describe it like if he's playing a
extremely strong Sicilian player he's
running into trouble you'll be trouble I
agree with with what you're saying and
maybe as a different repertoire in
classical but he can't be happy with
these positions box getting everything
here yeah
and now with the night coming to b6
everyone you see very common next moves
happening and night at 5:00 so this is a
this is a shot you to be aware but one
of the one of the issues just to
highlight for white is that even an even
a simple move here for black I'm gonna
say castles you might even already be
you know okay you can't castle okay be
687 okay this just but even if you even
if you trade on f5 and go for the bishop
b6 Queen d5 and Castle after that like
these types of positions are you know
black has B for coming
yeah no they get double edged for sure
and then black get some kind of thing I
mean are you sacrificing upon there
though yeah I mean queen of five before
I guess my thought was that the dark
squares become an issue but maybe maybe
it's not enough minor pieces lovely
force though I think like a stick on
afar so maybe we'll look into that but
yeah yeah as you described boxing go for
before white picks up upon we're gonna
see that line I think takes d5 I think
black will Castle and because if you
play g6 you run into Queen e5 yeah well
and Queen d7 is just officer yes I think
I think castles will because yeah unless
he was looking at Queen e6 but otherwise
no I think castles and now so this is a
night or five type of imbalance where
black is gonna play for b4 and I guess
the problem for for black is if white
gets Bishop d3 and g6 is forced because
of the battery then aged five now has a
target so c5 that wasn't what you were
no that's not what I wanted down upon
and that's just cuz obviously Bishop
doesn't mean blacks okay he's you know
he's submitting to groveling for a draw
here yes and firoozeh will he's up a
minute by the way and all the other
games
was done on time this is not a good
start what is that about
I think it's some of the time management
you see players who are down on time in
the five-minute portion are not always
down on time in the faster portion so I
just good clock management knowing what
they have as far as their ability to
think maybe I don't know I think that I
would be surprised if as the time
controls get faster ali reza is not up
on time more and more so this is such a
promising end game for while you're
gonna play b4 at some point fix the
phones on light squares go for the
queenside where you have a majority and
and even with opposite bishops I think
whites it's getting a passed pawn pretty
quickly you can't have a pair of rooks
and play p4 otherwise another idea maybe
just put a bishop on d5 and try to play
around that but I just like the idea of
fixing beat playing before playing a
four at some point getting those bombs
going at some point as well you're
probably going to give up h4 but
hopefully by that time the Queen says
already yeah now if you can fix the
pawns on the light squares probably
whites Queen side runs faster than
anything black can get over here but
yeah honey
for example Rotex da at some point
Bishop d3 before they for those would be
my next few moves so rook da wrote e8
Bishop b3 b4 and then you said c4 c4 84
yeah yeah and that's who's fast yep it's
also limiting counter play to right and
those lines here not allowing oh okay
well he plays in a different way and as
you've talked about it's he just he
still tries to kill you it's not
necessary like this is almost like
attempting he's almost trying to provoke
I don't know well yeah and it's
unnecessary to because I mean if the
pure opposite code Bishop ending happens
are you really winning both those pawns
on the Queen side maybe you are maybe he
thinks that in something if ruk t1 rook
t1 Bishop g5 white was gonna play d4 and
then Bishop b7 and yeah then it would be
three pawns yeah yeah it works I guess
it worked but you're I mean this is
Reza's style he's gonna be he's
convinced us that it works
just as important right yeah he's the
kind of player that you know there's uh
there's a brick wall and he and he's
gonna bust through it despite the fact
that there's a door right next to it
right you know I mean and some to in
some ways that style just really pays
off and sometimes it can seem like he
takes the the path of most resistance
but but he's still playing for two
results here a position that white can't
really lose yeah here okay five you put
the bishop on d3 you're gonna win eighty
six bond and and two connected past
bonds beats one X upon every day of the
week like if by Quinn's g5 at some plane
that doesn't do you so even see five
right now yeah I was gonna say even just
give up the pawn and say you know what I
get a six here come see six this is very
nice technique they're just limiting
things like check we see Martinez
Alcantara living on the increment here
unfortunately he's going to need a
little more than that because yes these
past fall hands are honestly this might
be this in my out on a limb to say this
is the smoothest victory we've seen so
far Eric yep I mean it's it seems like
it right it feels like we've got it we
just saw a game that from start to
finish was very very clean I really have
to question the Queen trade there
especially in the match situation like
you can just play down upon but with
Queens on and some attacking prospects
trading off is a little depressing but
yeah at the same time you know the score
is pretty pretty imbalanced right now
that you have to yes I think that yeah
just from a practical point of view
right and what we're talking about is is
the position where the position were
black elected to play the move Queen to
c5 rather than something like b4 and go
for an obstacle Bishop style attack of
a4 maybe b3 I mean you're just you're
trying to create counter play yeah
it takes obviously you have situations
where the B file and the b2 squared
become an issue so I'm with you a
hundred percent and I think it was just
a sign of the difficult times for for
Jospeh more
it's Alcantara here the contrast there
Jerusha wouldn't have offered a queen
trader he was down upon you'd continue
attacking right but yeah it does have a
luxury right now well six-point lead and
most of us favor fuchsia in the bull
portions so there's a time to score some
points when you think it's the Flitz
where where the positions in general
have been pretty dynamic from both sides
and there's been opportunities even here
we'll actually blacks very active in
this position a firoozeh in positions
that are very open he's exceptionally
dangerous just like a car
these guys look for tactics very fast
calculators and don't mind playing with
imbalances another Spanish but you know
one thing about these two players is
we've seen different openings even with
the same start to the opening we've seen
different types of structures different
types of middle games reached from a lot
of these different positions shout out
to chess ucation there thanks for being
here yeah thanks all the subs you guys
are racking up I think I saw close to
600 drivers yeah I don't even know I
think I don't know how you keep track of
that no maybe maybe not though but we do
have 3200 people watching and this is
kind of what the people pay for I mean
regardless of the lopsided match I think
a lot of people had this one circle
because they want to see what ali reza
does when he's the favorite nervously to
only the four seed overall but in many
people's eyes one of the top one of the
top picks to win this thing you're gonna
have people predicting him not only to
be a favorite to win this but to do well
if you were to qualify for the main
bracket right yes you see this is like
this is a storyline you're watching Ali
Razi plays every day on chess calm yes
just watching his sparring let's say and
he's got the bullet event this event and
it's just like yeah it's uh some people
I think a lot of people like that I I
mean we'll be talking about that us this
match goes on you know I don't really
know that I would have him is the
favorite Oh
someone like Wei Yi if we want to talk
about the the schedule and and who else
is lined up in regards to this match I
mean I still look at where Yi obviously
he has to get by the young Indian star
pregnant Anna but he's the strongest
player in the field and let's not forget
he was invited to the main SEC last year
I even saw someone in the chat saying
wait wait he's a junior still right I
mean when you get into chess
pound-for-pound this is gonna be an
interesting discussion if Wei Yi and
foucha throw down but alright that's
that's for future of future discussion I
guess that's the dream mattress yep
so if you were I guess what I'm saying
is if you put me against the wall and
said Danny you have to choose a favorite
right now I mean I I might still lean
the top seed for a reason the number one
overall being the young man from China
but okay I think I think it'll be it'll
be fun to see as this goes on and
certainly for sure for sure and certain
again like we said this in the first
match Eric with Jordan Vaughn for Easter
you know taking on Ariane Terry that I
mean both of those good that's not gonna
be an easy out next round either with
your winning I mean this is the you know
I don't really know and nobody knows and
I think with juniors they're their kids
for a reason because inconsistencies and
growing pains are even more likely and I
think I think it'll be have us on the
edge of our seats all year all season so
we need for right now again a good
position here for Martinez Alcantara but
will it be enough we've given that he's
down on the on the clock well yeah I
think means on the board if I can get in
yeah could be seven looks like a very
natural move yeah Quinn be seven or to
put the battery all that diagonal block
should be actually happy this position
the pawns are in light squares in the
Queen set visual on c6 is excellent and
whites been relying on tactics trying to
hold things together like maybe even now
in 96 try to kick off of that day I know
but after Queen d7 this is better than
night yeah and the bishop is actually
hitting things on both sides of the
board and variations like that so this
97 Queen c7 again a 4 and F 3 on 3 so do
you have time you don't time to play
with t1 or exceed over t1 a for saying
exceed 140 a comes yeah definitely
issues here I mean are we gonna see net
f5 ooh
Knight f5 and visa threatens checkmate
right in this Queen c4 check that looks
very dangerous yeah 9 506 Queen c4 water
so why don't he play that in five really
strong huh
okay well Martinez Alcantara played
Queen c5 and has only now put the pony
on the F square I I agree with you Eric
I think the night at five right away
there that was now what if I play d5
yeah now rook d5 is coming in Queen c2
b3 b5 Queen c2 b3 Eric is trying to
overload the Queen oh it's certainly
this is favoring Bach opening things up
pieces Queen getting tied down well
we're gonna find out if that's the line
that all the resident likes he's played
rook d5 I'm not doing but bishop takes
after me here yeah Queens yeah you want
to get the Queen's off he doesn't want
to have double deaf pawns with blacks
but even here I mean black is probably
the only one who can win the knight can
come to h4 I'm looking at right away no
he goes night out for nine h4 was also
too right now to take on b2 and also
have 96 396 attitude yeah here comes
okay but even Brooke see to first
rook see to that this is tight here
comes Knight takes h3 f2 falls just good
technique here I mean this is just super
high-level chess along with an edge on
the clock and again right now the the
route is on unfortunately but it'll be
interesting to see how far for Usha can
go this is just
good old-fashioned family fun if you're
in Fergus corner you get to you get to
play tickle with the king this is so
hard to be white when you can't even
really pre move because your constant
worry about checks and then wonder his
rook yeah look at that will will back
this thing up and show you real quick on
the analysis board what just happened
there he played well he resigned but
will still show it he played the move
rook to c3 bluffing at the fact that the
B for pawn was hanging it was only a
trick silly rabbit tricks are for kids
and after takes rook c1 and 93 and those
are the kind of games you remember just
as a sign I guess of all the residents
kind of dominance in the match and just
swindles swindles and tricks galore
nastiness it hurts no but he punishes
yeah and you know those sort of tactics
just pop out like we always mentioned
guys like a Cara Nakamura you said we
probably haven't seen an online talent
like this and you know at least as far
as you know what we observe in the chest
calm community and and Eric we've talked
about in different times that without
the internet you know without ICC for
years right hey Cara Nakamura probably
doesn't become Makar Nakamura right and
then you know you have world champions
from cultures like Norway where in
previous years without a very strong
local chess culture would you see a
talent like that be able to rise so
quickly probably not right that with not
tected without technology without access
to grandmasters all over the world on
the Internet and then you look at what's
happening right now in Iran right you
look at only Reza firoozeh Parham ugh
Sulu the world junior champion also
gonna be playing in the junior speeches
championship and you just have to look
at that how cool that is right these
guys can play chess online and and get
access to the world's best chess players
from the youngest of ages without it
without it do we see the boom of all the
reza firoozeh and porom ugh who do
probably not right you probably don't
see these guys get so good so fast
no the environment environment plays a
big part and there's online access is
huge right even for me I just wouldn't
be he wouldn't be in a Grand Master
without the internet
by the way there's some theory I think
this sounds really dangerous for I don't
have blocked me a mistake but I don't
think White's supposed to get this
position something tells me that what's
something told me that back in this
position here where he first played f5
and then Knight g5 the fact that you're
willing to just laugh in the face of
danger of a piece something
so after f6 if black had taken g5 now
that's that's a very I just I think I've
seen someone lose like that that's
something I think it's Queen h5 I think
so right
something something nasty here but okay
obviously firuze your plans so quick
leave it he knows something's going on
here now the rook comes to a3 and this
is just a very quick switch I don't know
everything is about to come to life here
look at this 94 you're gonna have two
bishops and two rooks having a ton of
fun over here on the Kings side I love
this move by the way 94 you have to take
it if you if you defend the bishop by
moving it probably this night pops in to
c6
yeah c6 some lines that five might even
work just because the attack is winning
but this position is just this looks
awful in blitz and clearly based on the
clock you can tell something's gone
wrong
yeah but this is Martinez Alcantara
deviating Danny which surprises me not
only because he's not remembering theory
here doesn't know it but he was doing
well in Sicily yeah relatively multiple
down on the clock
again you can hold this this will be big
maybe 96 96 Queen h5 and after Bishop g5
brings swing the rooks over something
like that I have a couple ideas
I like 96 knots and I think the real
convey it just yeah I was gonna say I
like 96 even if you don't take the
exchange just like you said 96 Queen h5
bring the other rook over
I mean I assume h6 is a problem so you
got to play rook h8 I bring the other
rook over and feels very scary for black
know all the arrests that goes greedy
takes the rook a little surprise but
probably still good for white probably
unfortunately everything is good I
wonder if there's like an h4 move that
works in any of these lines with some
sacrifice okay he wants to just take on
a 69 Bishop takes h6
although xf64 takes c1 so you need to
prepare it a little bit but still all
right right now it gets frustrating
because you've got you know one player
going going on all cylinders clearly Ali
Reza is just clicking right now and then
you've got Martinez Alcantara who on the
on the chess board has not been this
many games worse in the match I mean
there have been a lot of opportunities
but but all skills considered that's
what defines who's gonna be the best
players in these matches and on that
note our daily question let's remind you
one of them was of all these players in
the Junior speeches championship who do
you think will be the best ultimately
best in terms of how we measure that
with chess is world champion Eric gave
some great insight in the first segment
if you missed it when I asked him what
he looks for like besides the ratings
what are those little ingredients that
you look for and he said that when you
see the young players from not wanting a
draw or rating point like wanting that
scalp right Eric when you see that that
magnus carlsen factor play for a win
against Aronian in the last round of the
Sinquefield cup when you don't need to
write when you have that and I think
Olly Reza has a little bit of that it's
almost like an ambition that borders on
just super aggression right at times
where he wants to just not only beat you
he wants to destroy you right and ali
reza has a little bit of that in him for
sure
i wonder if you can play h for you as a
nasty move first h4 and after Bishop
takes then queen tags that might be a
good way I'm trying to find a nice way
to liquidate you can win the Queen here
yes by taking if six right but he's
gonna take some time
he's got okay variation kind of a fancy
way to do it I love that tactic that
happens so fast let's show it takes take
shake-and-bake white wins back all the
material and then some
yeah this is just this is just good for
what I mean so he's converting it
[Music]
wouldn't that be a sweet little mate
yeah it's it's just a sack and a bowl
full of jelly nothing to it the King
runs out to have three but it's worth
worth worth a try yeah worth a try and
you know it gives gives the fan
something to you know go oMG emote about
right I I overreact to tactics all the
time it's it's actually my thing
so after tic age 3 kingi to wreckage to
tracking of 3G to is the idea right yeah
so that's what he's thinking not because
because you have to take the bishop
that's Kings you to check and then g2
here it comes it's on the board
resourceful Danny
now 94 check is also in play wait a
second if you play g1 next you Queen
with check and see two's hanging yeah
[Music]
Wow ok let's let's show this real quick
that was amazing lets show let's show
that moment real quick look at this hey
Eric you called it though this was a lot
trickier for the King to figure out than
we thought if you moved the rook it was
still gonna be a queen and the Queen
comes with check and the bishop falls at
the end of the line so all he reza sees
that and thinks he's solving it by
taking e2 but instead of trading into
the equal rook ending black gets a queen
with check and white just resigns on the
spot absolutely absolutely hilarious
fascinating and actually maybe one of
the few blunders we've seen by all the
rez all day for sure I mean you quoted
you know you mentioned that that was
what Martinez Alcantara referenced best
advice he'd been given by chess coach
right and and there was that hope there
was that idea that you could get some
kind of play in the age file and and he
went for it good on him because other
people I was gonna say he finally
returns the favor right ali reza has
done
a few times today won a game he had no
business winning and there you go yeah
okay well the the match the match
continues thanks you know that changes
things a little bit like the philia
question from the match has changed
because it was just a one-way street
before my positions anyone's bad
positions and now now at least maybe
I'll inspire Martinez up there to be a
bit more aggressive because honestly
when I sing a lot I saw Perugia struggle
Dani a bit those when Daniel was
attacking him yeah and and bringing
bringing the the fight right to the
doorstep so he could have done stuff
like that in normal positions we had
Sicilian positions we've had sharp
normal positions where he can be a
little more aggressive and we're gonna
look for that now this unfortunately is
a position where black gets a pretty
free attack and I'm not a big fan around
about you Danny
the be Foursquare is nice he's nice I'm
gonna put my pawn on c7 and c6 and block
that Bishop on g2 from getting too
powerful this is going to have five well
and plus you're already accelerate I
mean you're you're a couple of moves
okay 94 stop them if I was gonna
highlight but black was gonna play Queen
f6 to h6 and the h-file is it's already
under fire but I mean okay so that would
be the one way this backfires for black
as if Y can open things up quickly yeah
here White's threatening to maybe take
e5 and play nice c5 yeah so let's let's
go c6 the one thing that made me pause
there when we were talking about is when
I looked at the clock I'm thinking all
right well clearly Martinez Alcantara
doesn't feel well he doesn't feel lost
yet right I mean he's playing quickly
enough to say that it looks a little
messy nice c5 is a move
take c5 the problem with both those is I
don't think you really want a Queen
trade the light squares are just so weak
for white with the night on b4 but but
if you don't queen Trin it's hard to
that one yeah
what do you think is he gonna play nice
c5 here by c5 takes takes a big uncie
father would take no I don't know if you
take auntie one of the end b7 hangs
right no I can bring my Knight to d5
okay I don't like that white is so we
can lights Krishna then ate some before
that's too good of a piece yeah
even the end games are fine the bishop
hair is not strong I don't think it's
hatred backside the Knight to c3 how
does the move that's very classy feeling
no rush you don't I mean like yeah move
my knight another way support the center
open up the light square bishop
interesting stuff so again he's he's
down on the clock though I mean page
three here or like something like that
yeah I love it go full made a sorry sack
sack made right to avoid the Queen trade
on d5 right there's night afore in some
of the positions that have takes shakes
g5 I don't think yeah well there's moves
even like night age 5 as crazy as that
seems to block the h-file yeah we may
actually see something like that they
they went for this line and I was
thinking that if you've not aged five
all the roads are kind of shook his head
there he decides to go in for cleanup
five because now if Queen f3 g5 and
rotates to check very nice and it's an
idea g5 is stronger now too with the
Queen and play so and a strong addition
and worst-case situation oh he went for
it oh but then he just gave the I roll I
think that's Nakamura number seven a
true blunder g5 because of Jesus with
the I role that's a we have Queen age 7
so just g5 here yeah g5 is the number 7
spot
but no mini slump he4 after g5 ok says I
believe it but then a worst-case
situation we pick up the pawn back on
you 5 and you have an attack and you can
do two but that's only if you pick up
the Pawnee 5 so we'll see yeah so he's
gonna go G 4 so he has some resources
and and he's up on time or 10 seconds
that's meaningful yeah so far so nice
for what if he somehow gets this win I
think you would be right Eric that that
was a big sign last game he didn't see
this I don't like the space that Danny
he could played that h3 deal but I'm
gonna probably play f6 f6 right now uh
he goes for it because if black ever
regains material blacks positioning
better White's got too many weak this is
right development I want to play
something like g4 and that f4 Eric okay
he goes for b3 but I want to find some
way to untie the tangled web I like this
Jesus or an f4 he's doing something then
he get 495 and now a bishop da yeah
still though I'm calling a now no
actually no f4 we didn't work anymore
cuz it be three but look at this wow
this is gonna be a crazy finish here
under time pressure too many tactics on
the board without this one pieces he's
gonna get the rook on age six yep down
to the wire down I mean this is you
gotta give us a tour credit here comes
tonight good very good nato 6f3 play it
through baby
see - and I start getting counter play
maybe not or ninety five is even better
if King F - Bishop c5
okay Brooke d3 in the night at five next
Bishop c5 then Ivor takes rook takes c6
okay but he'd only got one second oh my
god you just let me to spawn you just
blended the pun that takes you three Wow
Oh Oh buddy he actually blowing out here
b5 it's gonna be partners here Dani and
it King can't stop it but he gets a five
that's good he's got the connected
passers yeah it's two they should be
winning for white can you six for King
g7 but he's has he pushed too far daddy
just six seemed a little unnecessary
right bring the coin instead especially
with the time that all the Reds have had
right and okay this is gonna be a draw
but will quit will quickly click through
it and and show you real quick everyone
why this game why this game should have
been a win let's let's let's back this
thing up and show you that really
regardless of even whether there's a
better approach for black the point is
this move is just one step too far look
at the clock yeah I mean you had a
position where all the Reds have had
less than three seconds g6 was
unnecessary keep the pawns together
bring the king and the two passers up
the board one by one and this is a
winning endgame totally winning a game
provided especially with time pressure
but instead he he let this pawn get too
far and only resident held I'm looking
at the clock here I mean he was holding
that game on the increment Eric so
Martinez Alcantara really let that get
away yeah that was I thought he was
gonna get it there right at the end of
time scramble but okay that's a point
and a half out of the last two games I
mean despite it slipping you got to feel
a little bit better if you're if the
counter or the counter trade where he
gave up yeah look I supposed to sort of
just pick up the pawn right play a
slightly worse position he brought the
pressure to him he sacra penetrated with
the rook on the h-file brothers name to
f5 and in the end and up ahead after
that that was some nice I thought was a
nice aggressive play yeah to change the
momentum of the game well we have 27
minutes left here in the 3-1 portion
obviously the scoreboard speaks for
itself everyone no no denying the
storyline has been Olly Reza firoozeh
all day but but there's been
opportunities for this to be a closer
match and with a couple games now going
in the direction of the young Peruvian
maybe
Jazmin can can keep the momentum going
playing quickly now as black yeah up a
little bit on the clock with His Royal
Lopez which last game he he did score
point to swindle we'll see how this one
pans out there's been a trade on e5
Danny and that usually means that
there's gonna be a bit of a battle
around the d5 square the D files gonna
be contested and that's yeah revolve
around on the flip side blacks gonna try
to play b4 at some point and when the d4
square for himself at the right time
destabilize White's white Center we'll
see we'll see who gets their box very
active maybe 96 96 thank you for might
be wound and she Ford's an idea okay
gotta watch out for an edgy for you yeah
in fact so much so I was expecting
either him to voluntarily retreat the
Bishop to g7 or even play h5 but he
didn't looks very active for block bug
certainly has no opening issues in terms
of getting active getting pieces out so
now it's just down to the middle game in
positioning them I like this move queen
of one if he's gonna play chiii and kind
of pushed the Lions back at some point
you push it back for the Prophet g3 long
term is at least there's a bishop on b7
that's yeah that's a good point
eventually f5 becomes an issue yes okay
Bishop c6 right now keep things keep the
tension as opposed to right anything
keep the pawns right where they are I
think there's a tacking potential for
block here and this will be indicative
of how Martinez off guitar is playing
that I think you should seize the
initiative you can play aggressively
here black has comfortably equalized and
the key thing is you're just thinking at
some point black is gonna look for f5
right I mean yeah if you move the bishop
to c6 one second I don't like black as
much probably because I think your g5
move might be just concrete will you
play g3 sorry g3 and 95 that's
concerning me a little bit
g3 96 95 where are we putting our queen
maybe he's not like gonna stop g3 right
cuz like yeah Queen e6 designed to stop
g3 what if I take on b5 right now he
does it just he's just so ruthless when
the tactics are like again the move
before everyone this pawn was still
poisoned because of discoveries but you
give all the reza a second chance and
he's gonna he's gonna find those tactics
every time he wins the pawn he's gonna
take d7 the kid is good Ferruccio just
calculates ruthlessly yeah black might
do a desperate sac on h3 or something
but yeah I mean Alcantara might have to
I mean this doesn't lead anywhere
when you lose that one it's positioning
already lost he can actually still get
some material baby no no no and he
realizes it too he's like wait oh man
you did exactly what we were doing he
was like could I get something here and
then he was like no you know what was
funny about that Eric is I don't even
know that Martinez alcantara realized
how easily winning he was when he first
played it and all the sudden he's like
wait that's a queen that's the queen is
he gonna take back on c4 and play Bishop
a4 you can potentially get two pieces
okay Bishop a4 okay this is but let's
see how how easy this is to put away
this is where ali reza firoozeh is one
of the best in the world yes and
Martinez Alcantara sits up straight cuz
he knows that he's like look that I know
that I'm a between but this is not gonna
be easy in fact from a practical
perspective I mean are we really gonna
count all the Reza out here like yeah
rook d1 would have won the I think that
was a blunder by furusho I must be
missing something there yeah why I think
I think I was missing something I think
there's like an 85 move after rook do
you 195 something crazy I'm pretty sure
d1 95 and you
when the Queen but I get this rook with
Jack and then got it okay got it okay
but he's still getting counterplay smart
right right you just touched on that I
think that's something that strong
players you know teach teach our viewers
inadvertently just that you don't want
to be married to all the material if
you're up this much let your opponent
win some back just to simplify it out
and that's what he's doing here he's
like look yeah you're gonna win a rook
and I get it but you're still down way
too much c3s falling it makes my job
easier when the pieces come off the
board
yeah now he'll take c3 okay or offer
more trades but at some point here this
should start to get easier for black Wow
how often do you see a rook rook fork on
a diagonal that's a fork emote get him
out everybody the one four key mode in
the chat just you know this is actually
a challenge Eric that I was given by
Jessie cry recently at the Denver open
yeah he wanted me to make like a video
series on how often rooks get forked
because you never see this happen okay
no sorry it's specific how often are our
rooks forked by a queen because almost
always they can move and defend each
other right so we started coming up with
all the different ways that a queen
could have put a double attack on the
rooks and that was that was one right
there I hope you're watching Jessie
because there you go it does happen it
does exist two and half out of three the
comeback is alive and and if you're
firoozeh for the first time in in the
match now you have to stop the bleeding
right where is he going by the way - can
somebody tell them the curtains look
fine the chat here Chikara says why is
this kid acting like a two-year-old we
got some entertaining chat entertaining
but yeah we got it all right
let's see some more wins for me that's
more cases this is Creed and honestly
again if you're just joining us everyone
yes this is still a lopsided match but
but there's been games that could have
made this closer so I mean I do not
believe we're out of the woods if
someone tilting yet obviously we're not
out of the woods in the J SCC by any
means this is only the second match of
the year as you can see right there
plenty more action coming up especially
when June hits here it's like every
other week every other day I believe
that mug suit Lou Maroney match has been
moved to June 2nd I'll look for somebody
from our staff to confirm that for you
guys in chat but other than that the
schedule is what you see right there and
the quarterfinals and semifinals already
set in in advance so regardless of who
wins those are going to be the dates and
you can mark them down so if you're with
us for the first time hit that follow
button the junior speeches championship
it is real item 9 exists let's go let's
go right now the comeback Allie resident
needs to stop the bleeding which I want
to see him do because he hasn't been put
in a spot yet where he was on tilt right
Eric and this is his opportunity to show
he's gonna handle it before it's there
it's possible we'll see right he's
getting some nuts right now
he's eating some nuts trying to prevent
you know catastrophe but well that was
the position he was winning so he's lost
yeah I mean his play overall is still
pretty good and barring some more you
know we just blend errs and yeah and for
sure obviously the match is still very
much you know in hand right now for
Auliya Reza you know covering it from
start to finish and thinking about every
game we've seen knowing that there have
been some the Martinez alcántara really
let's let even even a couple that he was
winning when he lost on time or was
swindled so you know this is where you
got to see if all the res that can come
calm his nerves
he's the favorite here but everything
you're doing is training to win the
whole match and he's not always gonna be
the favorite I don't think and so this
is it right here a good a good
opportunity to see how he handles the
momentum I think white just messed up
the opening a little bit though after
this I think you can just play for Fi
like to say you can play from five right
over it right away even yet for next and
I think it this move right here as soon
as you see 97 played and there's no
tactical consequence for that retreat
then you know this Bishop has has
wandered too far
you should have traded it earlier or
something right because one thing was I
mean what place is hoping to win the
bishop pair and that didn't happen so
right yeah this is already looking like
all the rest will be weathering the
storm I mean this is a good position for
black whoa a lot of pieces for the Queen
though I was saying good position for
black on e4 cuz I think like everybody
else I was assuming the Queen had to
move but Martinez Alcantara says not so
fast yeah I mean he's got a what in the
world I mean if this is a third a third
game that doesn't go all here as his way
then he's got real problems
yeah Bishop f4 I don't know Ricky to
like Queen after reason annoying move
because you can maybe Queen f3 just
Bishop Queen is also just rook d4
there's work d4 I was thinking yeah yeah
route before
there's also Brook III now if you want
to play an intermezzo to kick the Queen
out Queen c6 rook d6 I mean this is this
should be enough piece is this fell this
fell apart I mean now even just bring
the other rook to e7
you're gonna blend enough for it oh I
was kidding I was testing you you passed
[Laughter]
it could be good here as Knight h5 let's
yet you could go rookie 7 Queen now for
uptake c7 was that your test some sort
of yeah I was also testing you in a
secret way second and you passed again
thank you for thank you for bringing
your A game today Eric
no obviously economy but that's why we
pay you so so I'm gonna see all black
can do though is January dressed as a
queen right your world will never leave
faith because too many pieces for white
around potentially around blacks King
that another you probably have to keep
one work to defend and the Queen just
runs around defending rook rook f7 now I
woke up seven roti a check it's looking
bad let's see how ali reza deals with
this one but alright so rookie seven
Ricky eight but still there's just too
much material
what happens after be through just gonna
go for the ending like down a piece I
guess it has to be 3v3
Queen B five C for the rook falls so I
think he's gonna he's gonna sit back and
be frustrated because he clearly is not
happy with how he's calculating Brooke I
mean that reaction told me he didn't
even see b3 Eric does he go to here
first
rook rook d2 would have been is gonna go
for g5 yep
no Bishop III c5 should follow me this
should be enough oh he's gonna allow f3
well that's what you were allowing he
doesn't have okay Bishop e8 he still has
time I was already the line I was
allowing there because I was I was
getting excited to see five fun and then
f3 and that's how Dani loses chess games
right there check rookie six check okay
okay should be winning for white
Alcantara has weathered the storm a six
or D are you getting made you're not
getting made
there was no many were here why Bishop
e7 I have no idea just pushed what you
know what I think it also guards f2 so
in some positions he was okay I agree
with you it seems like you can go
searching far and wide yeah give check
Bishop and play a seventh
even right now you can put the King on
each two especially because there's no
problems on f2 that's gonna they should
be three or just go get a queen good
enough and it's gonna be good enough for
the comeback to continue I mean people
thought the hype train right they're
like oh you're just adding hype I think
that the right now I think the comeback
train is real Israel he's uh he just
made this a four-point match if you're
just joining us everyone this is um this
has been Olly Reza firoozeh all day but
again in the 5-1 portion it would not be
crazy to say that Martinez Alcantara had
opportunities so if this if this is not
if the ship is not righted here by
firoozeh these are young kids for a
reason you know he doesn't want to drop
below 3,000 because then he's got to
hear it from mikaru and all that stuff
right so right now there's emotions
going on in all the residents to needs
to talk about gotta get him out Daniel
Rose's play this match so far
I mean highly-touted you know player I
mean not right now no right now I feel
like he's he's not he's not whether
right you know Oh as a whole lot very
impressed I mean as a whole I think he's
not as a player a beer you're asking so
many questions I think okay sure no I'm
with you here's what I would say I think
all the Reza is going to win this match
and he's been the better player of the
scoreboard speaks for that but he's been
worse consistently as white by the way
he might be worse again and if you're
just joining us everyone that wasn't
necessarily crazy I mean this has been
he's been in dubious night-horses white
all day he's won several games by time
pressure swindle so obviously the
firoozeh hype and the fan base is there
for a reason and shout out to all the
subs coming and thank you so much but
but I'm with you Erik this has not been
the kind of performance by somebody
who's a favor to win the J SCC is that
where you're going with this yes you
feel like there's quite a few he has
quite a few
most Apache up I mean there's a lot of
opportunities right loose corn upset
when you write the games
yeah the upset may not have been here
but as I said right no there's a reason
why I I personally favor the strongest
player in the field way ye I think to
win the whole thing um and I think
obviously I think the juniors that are
so talented anybody could be wrong or
right at any time but but okay I think
that there's some there's some signs
here that Ollie Reza is gonna have to
make sure he fixes some opening holes
against the strongest players you can't
be worse out of the first stage
consistently even if you are good at
flagging people so unpolished
yeah unpolished and unpolished or not he
is seem to be getting he doesn't be
getting most of our love on Twitter our
daily question everybody of course was
of all the players in the junior
speeches championship who do you think
is the best chance to become a world
champion and at kareena Kruk wfm says
her chances are on firoozeh he's 15 and
he already has experience against top
GM's such as World Chess Champion Magnus
Carlsen for sure faroush is gonna be
among the among the favorites and thank
you for getting involved use the hashtag
speech s on Twitter you can also give
your opinion and twitch chat we love if
you just orange STV chat but if you want
to get involved on social media we
appreciate that and use the hashtag when
you do it all right what do we got here
well we have black getting a very
playable position with the Sicilian
again and technically I just up upon
whether you can hold onto that as a
different story but no opening problems
whatsoever
we should come start getting just
getting very very poor positions as
white consistently I thought he would do
a little better Danny I thought
especially the white he's gonna put a
lot of pressure on his opponent today
but yeah I feel like and there's to
still some time left I mean this could
end up getting even closer before we hit
the bullet stage because this game even
this game yeah yeah g6 looks like an
automatic okay maybe Queen h6 is coming
is that weird look g6 Queen H doesn't
necessarily come with the threat but
just as it there's also f4 in a lot of
these positions and
there's frizz but blog really message
have the confidence knowing that he's
played good moves he's up a bond even
though fujas is playing some aggressive
knows that he shouldn't actually be
worse or you shouldn't actually be
losing by an attack if you've done
nothing wrong like should it just be you
know I mean yep he goes Queen age six
okay I think you have to be ready to
call White's Bluff I mean are you gonna
play nice c4 and just say I'm not really
afraid of Bishop takes g6 what do you
consider night h7 here to try to play
Queen g5 and three things on how I like
it
at age seven with Queen g5 I like it I
mean you're asking the wrong person if
I'd consider i'ma try chess you'll you
know I try a lot of things but so I'm
into it but I'm as well apparently
Martinez Alcantara is well that's a nice
move here comes Queen f6 yeah just
putting the kibosh on him where's the
beef right where's the bait no there's
nothing I mean you play fruga he plays
you can play hyper aggressive he wins a
lot about positions you have to call to
be confident to call out some of the
groups and now I think finally Martinez
Alcantara was getting into the groove
where he's like my calculations on point
there is nothing here for firoozeh and
Queen g5 is play who do his purpose okay
this is actually a little tricky though
because yeah species aren't very well
coordinated d6 is a weakness net on b6
hasn't entered the game and where do you
put the net on u6 because of 96 and ff5
net age 3 just looks a little sad maybe
broke out 400 f3 what do you do have to
work health one owned a TV ad like this
but 95 92 then I'm still playing work f3
95 92 looks a little awkward here
firoozeh is so resourceful there is g5
coming for a while but the g5 if you
play g5 I take and you're no you're
worse you're up upon but your structure
is all oh my gosh for 5 didn't see that
what a sick move by firoozeh look at
that move that's for 16 on at 5 position
yeah and the knight is trapped on h3
actually that's a nice that's a nice
fine to sack the exchange buy it which
is why I'm not
maybe would have done what I was okay
yeah maybe yours maybe your approach was
but I thought ferocious move was was
brilliant in hindsight probably but I I
didn't like Bishop f5 I I thought you
could just drop the night yeah yeah
wait it looked it looks so strong and
then you know with this exchange sac
they're nice resourceful decision by
Martinez Alcantara we're gonna see a
growth times carnival where black has
black has kingside pollens his
compensation I mean there we go right
here's how accurate black can play with
a time situation because there's one
down replay and but 17 seconds and you
sort of missed up the tables turned
pretty fast bruises hey karo says this
should be winning for black in a normal
game but in blitz he's doubtful time
pressure has always favored firoozeh all
day at least in terms of who's been able
to hold their own not blunder I mean
obviously right that's been kind of the
expected storyline that faroush it would
be better but but maybe Alcantara having
had a few wins now is feeling it a
little bit we'll see if he can handle
himself here on the time pressure well
he's definitely feeling it because I
mean I feel like he is playing playing
better coordinating the pawns is the
tricky part you have to slowly put yeah
it's so hard to do is like you know it
looks good enough for but then it blocks
your on but but this was a strong
approach here the rook now guards a fort
he's threatening g4 g3 here it comes
panic a little bit here yep in a
position now is black where you can
check check and then the knight comes
over if King c1 knight Knight to e2 he's
got a play King a1 so that was worth the
try he's got a defend but again still
still very annoying ok that's a good one
ok I he's playing tickle I'm not sure I
like that as a good sign I think that
that's well now aged through the palms
are fixed peruggia's got another chance
to Danny oh he's going for Ricky - he
just won for rookie - and he's gonna go
get the get the H pawn
is he running in Oh King e6 was accurate
93 what's the idea he's getting h2 okay
but it's like weathered the storm it
feels like it but still very little time
on the clock now g-49 f2 no they didn't
he figured it out Burnett of three in
King's refunds
time time time I think all the rest have
figured it out bring if Rick f1 is just
is just giving up the ghost there's no
way this is good brew should do what he
does winning the time scramble
absolutely
push the f1 it's thought we've seen
we've seen the nights are tricky right
yes but that is fast yeah but I gotta
admit this has been I've been impressive
by firoozeh because from start and from
start to finish of the time scramble it
was it was that was a very tricky
position for white to play playing
against the night playing it's the pawns
but firoozeh finally stops the bleeding
but right before this moment everyone if
you're just joining us
Alcantara was it was on a comeback he
had won he had won three of the last
four games and we you know you wanted to
see whether one of the favorites overall
that being firoozeh could could weather
the storm and stop the tilt and he did
it right there so okay this is gonna be
our last three-minute game right here so
big moment right now if you're Martinez
Alcantara show that you can stay in the
match right firoozeh weathered the storm
but don't let your momentum slide away
you got to find a way to get a victory
here 4000 people with us Martinez is
mounting a comeback but everything's
going to go his way and that game was
one of them
you know yeah I was that was one of them
I thought like the close games need to
go his way and that one he had all the
opportunity through Asia health yeah
amazing stuff there again very
impressive right now
by ali reza firoozeh but martinez
Alcantara wants to get wants to get as
much momentum as he can't heading into
bullet because that's really where we
know we know that firoozeh is is among
the world's elite elite elite
we're getting position we've had a few
times where firuze it doesn't - d6
weakness he just says hey I got all this
counter play but if you remember Danny
in the 5-1 stage Perugia final game
right where he was down when he held in
the end all right yes be doing wall but
he repeats it like so I mean he's
resourceful even when it's not going
yeah not going well and I think that's
one of the the trademarks of ferocious
chess and tomorrow we will we will
launch a new trademark for chess calm we
have the women's speeches championship
along with the JSC see that you're
watching now for the first time the the
top female chess players in the planet
playing in an eighth player
invitation-only elite round robin the
one player to have qualified her way in
is danielle yin and she'll be taking on
top seed Katherine Katharina log no
tomorrow so if you didn't know what you
were doing
Wednesday morning 9:00 a.m. Pacific if
you're in the States you call it sake if
you're in Europe perfect way to come
home and make sure you tune in and see
the first match of the women's feet
Chess Championship tomorrow on a Rudolf
and so Coco gear how much really will
have the call and if you're in Canada
states in Europe that's right and and
those on the west coast in Canada you
know I didn't you know we didn't didn't
do anything one of my favorite fuel in
the world lives in Vancouver and you
know Steve Nash from Victoria very very
small place Inc I know my Canadian good
theory you know Steve Nash my favorite
Canadian of all time I'm not saying
you're not second Eric okay I love you
you know that name my kid after Steve
Nash okay did you actually
yeah I didn't know my oldest son is Nash
yes okay I didn't know after Steve Nash
oh it was a joke because the night we
found out my wife was pregnant with our
oldest kid we were we were Nash had like
a triple-double for the sons and it was
like if it's a boy we should name him
Nash and then we started thinking about
it like that's a really cute name and so
we went we actually started calling the
baby baby Nash even before we knew was a
baby boy or a girl so there we go
that's Danny trivia right there I did
not know that waiting for you to have
some more kids to know we're done now
we're done now but if we went if we went
further maybe maybe hanson and hamilton
make the Canadian Canadian list so well
firoozeh here you can take yeah I'm you
know just everything gets traded off
he's pretty comfortable about that good
Bishop on g7 nice seat file bark no
issues at all yeah easy game for black
and even if this is a peaceful result
it's probably a good result right now
for faroush ahead in two bullet where
you know you're one of the best in the
world be three plate it's a nice
defensive move there yeah you cannot
deny get to see four but um a pretty
comfortable way to end off the v1
portion for ya after a very very sketchy
middle middle part where or he lost a
few there some people probably weren't
expecting it to be ten five at this
stage especially with the way things
started out I was like plus six at some
point at the first ya know it was we
were we were at nine to two almost at
one point was it it was nine to two I
think yeah and yeah I'm not having any
more kids anyway base so don't you worry
although I like bay wrenches well you
know what else I like Fisher random
chess and we have the Fisher random
world chess championship rolling along
there's actually a lot of momentum
picking up I think people are realizing
there's only there's only four weeks
left to play in qualifying even if you
don't think you're gonna make it all the
way to Oslo to play Magnus Carlsen or
Hikaru Nakamura you still have a chance
to qualify and playing the title player
stage so go too far Ches calm for more
info and try to play there's gonna be a
lot more commentary starting with with
this point forward on Sunday you can
follow commentary it right here on this
channel or it slash chess comm events
that's our other channel when we have
too many too much stuff going on as Eric
said we got a lot going on so um anyway
check it out Fischer random chess and
see if you want to qualify for the world
Fisher random Chess Championship yeah
he's gonna try to qualify yeah yeah we
actually have a lot of title players
that have already I don't think I don't
think all the title players got the memo
because a lot of them are used to title
Tuesday where it's free even title
players have to pay an entry to play in
the later phases so at some point they
were like oh wait there's like a lot of
prize money even just to play in the
online portion all right fine I'll pay
an entry so I expect the title player
entries to go up here at some point yeah
well in the meantime has picked up upon
he's out playing and it's already game
over it's already it's already you got
your second two pawns are good yeah he's
crushing it Bush Ollie ollie Reza is
showing why he is one of the best and
again I guess the big thing was you know
when you found yourself losing a few in
a row you got it you got to recover and
he was able to do that he may end up
taking now his own momentum a two game
in a row streak into the bullet if he
wins us this up he should be winning
this but I can see it happening because
we're just going on maybe bring the king
in the pretty much white wants to get a
pawn down on the F like pressure the net
on u6 so that the bishop on g7 becomes
loose yeah I like this little mini king
run now all he did was push the pawns in
worse Martina's Alcantar just gave like
a smile there he was like yeah that was
just like I came up with all this
resourceful counter play but it wasn't
enough to stop the pawns feels bad man
feels bad man and he's gonna he's gonna
resign and take his six game deficit
into the
bullet portion we are going to take one
of our last final breaks here before we
head to the bullet if you're with us
don't go anywhere when we return we will
tell you what our moment of the match
was in regards to some of the highlights
that we gathered throughout the day and
my bad not reminding everybody but for
those of you who've been doing clips we
really appreciate it you can make a clip
and share it in the twitch chat and your
clip might get chosen for the moment of
the match and you might win a diamond
membership so wow I totally dropped the
ball in promoting that shadow to our in
Hawaii let's give our studio C shout out
there Erin and there's our Clipper there
Josh wave your hand buddy that's that
guy's all he's doing is doing clips in
the background and he's got noise
cancelling headphones he doesn't even
know I'm talking to him there you are a
little late buddy little late alright
we're gonna be right back here with the
juniors features championship brought to
you by Jessica calm with our moment of
the match and the bullet portion Grand
Master Eric Hanson don't go anywhere
we'll be right back
[Music]
Fisher random chess a game where
creativity is king and memorization
impossible 960 different back rank
configurations from the world's best
chess players into mere competitors
trying to outwit and outclass each other
with every unprepared move only one will
be worthy of the title of Fisher random
chess champion but the best part is that
champion could be you the Fisher random
Chess Championship will be unlike any
tournament ever held with a global
qualification system for the first time
ever
everybody truly has a chance to prove
themselves the best player in the world
at a chess barrier are you a chess
artist worthy of the 11th world
champions admiration we're gonna find
out the tournament features open
qualifiers beginning on April 28 and the
title player qualifier stage
beginning in June over $300,000 Fabiano
Caruana Hikaru Nakamura and world
champion Magnus Carlsen await you at the
later stages the Fisher random Chess
Championship title is there for the
taking
will you make a run at it go to F our
chests calm today to register and stay
tuned to chest comm for all the latest
news and updates regarding this historic
event it's the feed a world Fisher
random Chess Championship organized by
dude a.s and chess calm
dances here I mean you got a pawn and a
bishop and your Kings active we've all
know but it's not enough time he could
have just taken g7 in 55 that was a
bluff and just absolutely even though
that's actually our first draw of the
five-minute portion which by the way is
I don't know what the stats are on that
but we don't often have eight games
played and only one peaceful one so that
was a super first of all shout out to
set for nine one who takes our moment of
the match for throwing us that clip
there she she he wins the clip of the
day and gets a diamond membership so
appreciate everyone who follows along
makes clips and and gives us things to
talk about so separ 91 you are you are
the winner there and thank you and Eric
that's really that's a moment that we
captured because it's a big one that
really defines and describes why Oliver
as of Arusha is so good right that
resourceful should have lost that game
and not only finds a way to hold it but
was almost winning in the end that was
we there were few moves there that we
didn't see coming like that d4 checkin
yeah and he just the kind of play came
out of nowhere I was a game that I mean
he was just playing down a piece yeah it
was just it's pretty incredible no
compensation and that's something you
can always rely on his ability but I was
gonna say show the separate anyone
that's good he's a notice him in our
chat he's a chess process up so I know I
said he she I always assume gender
neutrality in all names and I but as a
boy gets underway here we are headed for
our last segment here in the junior
speeches championship so if you're just
getting here you came just in time to
see what exactly is
ali reza firoozeh capable of and bullet
we we wonder that we know what he what
he does against the best players in the
world but in this format with increment
Eric we always said this is gonna be a
little different right this is not 100
it's not hyper bullet we'll see if
Martinez Alcantara can keep it close at
least a little bit yeah one one is the
time control where yeah we often see the
surprises in in that people who we don't
expect it too long bullet can be pretty
good at this although I think both
players you're pretty good at bullet but
Rouge it should be a heavy favorite
increment or not because we can sort of
there's some foreshadowing I mean we
suffer as you do well in the blitz
portion of the match when the games got
down to the wire what's difference
between that and one one I mean right
it's exact same time cruel time control
once they're down to 20 seconds if you
know earlier on you have less time to
build up a good position but they lead
to the same if you're right so from you
I think we have a bit of a glimpse and
and again we've seen we've seen night or
if I guess that's been the one very
consistent opening we've had all along I
guess with the the Spanish the Lopez
when Martinez Alcantara was white but it
hasn't necessarily been a super
impressive affair by firoozeh has widen
the night or although this one this one
looks like a positional positional
blinded white can be happy with maybe on
the Queen side and watch out for net
before Queen I thought that bullet work
should favor fusia heavily because he's
been playing poorly is white but now
last time on the clock is opponent
doesn't have enough time to punish you I
think it's gonna do really well because
it's actually gonna help yep well we see
a question there the chess TV chef our
Earl of thean is saying how long is it
gonna take for firoozeh to get to the
very top similar to our daily question
we asked everybody who they think in the
team your speech has championship has
the best to best chance of maybe
becoming a world champion right the
chance of becoming a world champion are
hard no matter how good you are right
you need a lot of things to go your way
but that's why we didn't say who will be
the next world champion or not that
presumptuous but who is the best chance
and I think faroush is definitely among
those and although let's see night
before in Queen a5 it
Landon the problem is it looks like
nothing but simplification I guess if e
for white has F 4 so there's really just
no no counter play for black out
if you four I'll take and Bishop c3 I'll
play down the exchange exactly to d6 now
sorry C 5 C 5 D 6 did you just miss you
5 D 6 Danny I see 5 g 6 well he finds it
the second time around and we're gonna
see this D pawn start running up the
board night or that would not make
Maxime vache the ground but on that note
let's talk about what our next unit
features championship matches because
Maxime Vashi the grog will actually be
joining the French commentary on May
31st with our own Kevin board e blitz
stream so if you happen to speak
francais or if you just like to see them
curse in French I'm kind of into that
sometimes an f-bomb in French just comes
just just it just gets me going
Eric I don't know about you so you know
if you if you want to watch the french
stream Maxime bashed a the Grove and
Kevin boardy will have the call on May
31st that's way II vs. Prague nandan ah
Prague nandan ah sorry that's gonna be a
good one
mark your calendar that is our next J
SCC match firoozeh the rout is on right
now I think this is going to get tough I
think Martinez Alcantar just needs to
have some fun enjoy the last 25 minutes
and and see what see where the ride goes
chess pate throwing the wrench hair you
mowed my way I got a haircut bay is that
because I can't name a kid after you if
I have more kids I would have to name
him but I'm not gonna have any more kids
alright
you know never seen hazel knows you're
her spirit animal the the twitch chat
has been hype all day thank you to
everyone who's been here this has been a
lot of fun the chefs TV chat also
having a lot of fun over there and
regardless of what happens here over the
last 25 minutes the jr. speed Chess
Championship this has been a lot of fun
Eric you you said that there's something
about this format with the young players
where it's not to say we know who was
gonna win the speech Chess Championship
match I think a lot of people pretty
much always knew we would have finals of
you know Magnus and Hikaru those two
guys are just on another level and
blitzen bullet but but but it really
feels like in this match other than a
few matchups like we just don't know
what's gonna happen weekend and week out
you know I really think it also helps
the people just feel more connected to
some of these matches because they're
watching the players develop and grow up
and rise and that's that's very cool and
we're watching the players jump off
camera and come back everything's okay
all the residue off his laptop I don't
think he actually did but that was
dropped out of the zoom cone and dropped
out of the laptop does someone who like
smash their tennis racquet have a better
chance of being a grandson winner than
someone who doesn't have set same thing
with a laptop you know I mean like yeah
so I think that's a good trait like
McEnroe I like the emotion yeah I mean I
don't know that he smashed his laptop
out of frustration I might have just
like you know had I get the feeling if
we flip the camera around there's like a
smorgasbord of Turkish treats in front
of him I don't know just like just
things that he can pull and pick out and
drink so maybe he just overloaded his
his arm space the title of your
autobiography all right
95 here Martinez Alcantara again like I
love the night orff
I just wanted a better score for the
night or if I was rooting bias Lee for
that opening but no I mean this has been
what we what we think a lot of people
expected here as far as the dominance of
all the reason someone who we want to
see go deep because I think a lot of
people want to see what he'll be capable
of against some of those that are higher
rated than him in the format like way
Yee so here comes the English attack now
this is my kind of night or firoozeh
there we go
jaesik faster this is actually g6 just
do it yeah push your baby this is what I
want okay just do it I don't even care
if each six is protected go you're doing
something wrong I know if you're making
me happy probably you're a moment away
from wondering jokes aside of about it
making me happy look at this wait what
what what what it's like a crushing
position for white that was there a
mouse up there that we didn't see what
was good I don't get it yes I don't know
Danny but there we go the water gallon
has returned I don't think I was his
best case all day against the Sicilian
that was textbook yeah that was a
textbook English attack it does not make
a lot of sense for for that to end in a
draw he returned the favor for lost game
oops anyway alright we're back to a
Spanish the other one we've we've seen
repeated from time to time we see those
those dancing emote heads going opposite
directions like like me and quality
chess moves just going different ways we
got guys here when tournaments in years
and then you're no longer in that boat
yeah alright well let's see
I like blacks position here I like
ferocious control over the sea file yes
it looks good and probably why should
just trade things off the thing about
this is if you only have the C file you
can shut it down like you
by Bishop to Bishop III here and the C
files not enough I don't know they both
kind of looked in like what's all he
reza gonna do next on camera find out
next time and the juniors B Chess
Championship returns that often it's so
dirty and ali reza shaking his head he's
like I don't even know if that's good
but I'm doing it it looks good it's
crushing the darks really good most
important piece on the board once black
wins that that Bishop can put itself on
e5 a night on h5 weird tactics on the
board now if you take there's discovered
checks of all kinds you can't oh no you
can't right you can take I didn't
realise as possible I'm not used to the
rook blocking the bishop on b1 like that
but yeah just just King takes h5 what
are we missing
yeah but d5s falling in some positions
and black is probably just fine only 20
seconds so this is the first like truly
equal time Scrabble we've had the night
on a4 covers Queen B to check there
aren't any checks here yeah this is this
is crushing for us I mean you can play
h5 at some point maybe not now we would
see some Queen b8 he's gonna go from the
back oh no nevermind what about h5 yeah
Jeju nice move h5 again just great play
from black hair he's gonna take on g4 oh
there was so much going on right just
right and now he butters his Queen yeah
he sits back and tips his hat another
great game there from firoozeh and the
legend continues it's now an eight game
lead with roughly 19 minutes to play
good stuff well again we've we've
already mentioned everybody while we
have you of course
tomorrow is the women's features
championship first match of the year so
if you mark your calendar do that you
and I will not have the call it'll be on
a Rudolph and
so poco ger Amash feely but uh
anyway it'll be some interesting
interview questions I think after this I
mean I want to I want to ask Holly Reza
how he feels that he handled that moment
where you know a few games got away from
him how does he how does he know he's
gonna have to handle his nerves in big
matches when things like that happen and
how he feels about the tilt factor he
plays so much chess online how does he
feel that he handles himself in those
moments yeah he did pretty well today
because I mean he did recover fairly
fast and I don't feel like he made a lot
of like huge mistakes you know it wasn't
like you see that guy's opening he
starts pushing his h-bond like it's it's
a it's a control tool it's a controlled
so I think one thing that helps this is
when you're losing games we have such a
big lead that it's not like you the
feeling setting in that I'm gonna lose
this match like this is awful I'm
masking everything up he was always
always in a comfortable position I used
to be some scores
for was in maybe 795 good it's just so
good for white honestly ok well this way
Bishop takes f6 enter yeah play their
first queen chief or take on f4 with the
queen 5 in some positions I think we
also have to ask Martinez Alcantara how
he felt about the knight ourf in regards
to positions he was getting he never
went away from it I don't think he
should have but you know thinking of
some questions to talk with these guys
about I like this move rook d3 rook g3
Queen f5 or Queen h5 there's going to be
a puzzle rush tactic by Persia Wow no
checks 7 almost works no not quite
Queen Queen takes h6 first even better
you're right yeah here it comes
rook takes followed by mate and baked
mama helped g7 is a problem ali reza
firoozeh
is sending a message right now well we
talked about the fact that the only 1000
sweep that's ever happened in a in a
speech s championship match portion was
actually by Hikaru Nakamura over Hoey
thon in the three-minute portion of
their their first round matchup last
year that's not gonna happen here
Martinez Alcantara has already gotten on
the board but again this has been one of
those matches where you see what you see
what Ali Reza is capable of when he's
really rolling mm-hmm
I mean I think his opponent I think
Martinez Alcantara out of the field is
like not an easy first-round opponent
this guy is speed chest ratings online
and he plays a lot like right the good
value for the rating like he's
underrated yeah and he would be a very
tough match for most guys in the field
because I've seen them eating some
strong players and and very very
resourceful yeah Perugia
so from that perspective even though
we've kind of said hey maybe this wasn't
necessarily you know a sign of the best
form by ali reza today but still the
fact that he got it done against
somebody who you would say is not a
first not a person on that ship that
everybody wants right a good sign for
firoozeh i think in the whole field he's
above average well shout-out to everyone
let us know if you have any questions if
you start throwing them our way in
twitch chat or just comm TV chat we may
spot them I may not see them but if
somebody sees them and it's a good one
maybe we'll ask the players that but
obviously gonna talk to them about the
you know some of the specifics of the
match today talk to all the resin for
word in the format and and if you have
any other questions let us know
so do it do it to it we will have
interviews with the players in less than
15 minutes right after this should be a
blast and just 94 and say hey where's
the house that night coming back in the
game
okay 98 good stuff
yeah one of the questions I'm wondering
is which player will push bruiser to
have to play his best to win you know
right it's like that unforgiving style
might be wayy as you mentioned this is
one right highest rated player in the
field who's very strong tactically but
who will call those Bluffs and and those
sacrifices right right is it happens a
lot
it happens a lot in a lot of it he does
he does calculate very well so he backs
it up the reason sometimes it works as
well it has worked in the past and
concretely and and that means the
occasional time where it's a little
dubious while players are inclined to
believe him because they've been burned
by it
yeah it's a good it'll be interested to
see oh I want to ask him who we've you
know give him a chance to to go full
confident hit car right tell us tell us
if anybody can beat him and I don't know
if he thinks anybody can beat him in
this match here but we'll ask him who he
thinks his toughest toughest opponent
might be the current psychological
effect against the juniors what he car
has against other players you can have
against his peers certainly big factors
psychology no it is I mean and I think
that you and I would agree that if
Martinez Alcantara was a little more
confident earlier it might have been a
closer match right I mean there were
some games they got away from him that
you know like you said I mean he lost
some games by not winning them right and
and eventually allowing firoozeh to get
the better of him at a time scramble
because he didn't win positions when he
could have White's trying to prevent a
tough one blocks when I didn't have fun
because then you can win that second one
right and okay excavator it should be a
draw here regardless but we'll see if
firoozeh is gonna come up with a swindle
the king can now run into f4 g5 you got
to be careful actually if your version
if the king gets to he's gonna cut off
the king he's gonna like this move to
coming into e4 yes okay now that the
Kings cut off Danny cut off that means
she
forks em like a fork in maniac oh my god
oh the fork pain is real and again you
could smell it right you started talking
about he cut the King off like we didn't
know how it was gonna happen but no
surprise that you know that's a fork the
whole family can enjoy if you know what
I'm talking about right there that was
caught on camera in the wild ali reza
firoozeh doing nasty things so his
opponent defended success feels like 20
moves before that King was cut off but
foods not fair accurate in that fair he
puts on a lot of pressure he's really
he's not just fast the time scrambles he
manages to play some some very tricky
most the same time yep and eventually
someone cracks brother Josh in the chest
of each at 0.3 chance to win that means
you're saying there's a chance one in a
million right at this point I think
mathematically with him out of time left
we're almost four almost in me the hook
um and book him right back I'm and gag
him territory
I'm and gag him that's a Canadian phrase
right sounds like sounds good sounds
like it right bishop takes up to
everybody's hanging I'm in this end game
you got a favor white because you have
the past seep on the double but maybe
blacks active enough anyway the
storyline here is just Oh Mike from
Ridgid when he's in his groove isn't
super scary very good right now he's
very very good in yeah right now this is
one that okay this one seems to be going
okay if you're if you're looking at it
from Martinez Alcantara perspective just
a win or a draw gets firoozeh back below
3,200 right moral victories
- Eddie the Eagle oh but don't make
yourself on h8 if you pushy for that be
it that be upon you wish you could have
back now you can't play you for because
of her g5 check he'll probably play
Bishop before rookie 7 okay I think a
four and I wanna have some Tricky's
prepared I think we're gonna start
pushing a seat bond right up right away
oh he's waiting for you for that's when
Richie fives coming yeah yeah it was
made but now the e pawn has been
surrounded come out with your hands up
you're surrounded played rook f5 no rook
air-five King g6 wait a minute do you
already trap his row he trapped his rook
with that you actually had no choice but
to give up the exchange still it's still
unclear Danny still not clear Martinez
is his bullet skills here because again
he's up the exchange he's got it past
that pawn why does some kind of play
yeah
if he engage five would have made it
self made it on h6 he should he needs to
win this he needs to win these positions
if he wants to be competitive in cereza
the food is so annoying here just making
it impossible to defend that pawn rook
g5 yeah and then you brought my king no
I brought my king out first if I was
four just so I never get made it on the
back rank cuz work g2 was concerned me
he doesn't care maybe I would be playing
Richard - Ricky - but now mark I don't
think Martinez alcântara saw that was a
good point mother go to c4 okay rook
check and we go six maybe how's that
rook check rook f6 down to ten seconds
we go six King a5 r a check pawn up oh
okay there should be three no the King
didn't get fine but he's still okay
mm-hmm draw mm-hmm I mean it's fun if
you're black why not go for King chief
or I guess see sixes all right
surprise rotating leaf axils could gain
something by playing for a win there but
okay yeah well seven minutes left we're
probably in the realm of just a few
games remaining before before the
interview portion begins so if you're
just getting here obviously it's uh it's
been an impressive day for the Iranian
maybe maybe junior speeches championship
favorite certainly many people's pick to
win the whole thing
and we're gonna have some questions for
them in just a moment so don't go
anywhere regardless of the finish here
I'm sure we'll see a couple more
exciting games but I'm pretty I'm pretty
pumped to see how all the Reza handles
some of our questions about but where
that where the J SCC goes for here from
here who he who he considers to be his
top rival in the format and and see what
the players have to say for themselves
about how today's chess games went so
four thousand of you with us we love
every single one of you like literally
every single one of you except for you
except for you that one guy you know who
you are what is that one guy has because
has just showed up in the chat it's
funny Oh
firuze you lost connection and they
agreed to lose is that what happened
okay Hess's Hess is in the the staff
slack chat so maybe that's actually
factual information Hess doesn't usually
say things like that less is true so
that might explain the drawers I guess
you and I didn't see that did you see
them talking about that oh I didn't see
them talking about that okay there you
go
that's that's a classy move there by
Martinez Alcantara if they agreed to
drawers because of all the ugly roses
connection but what's strange is he
never disconnected from the Xoom call or
meaning our video chat so that's that's
a weird thing if he if he did have a bad
connection there for a little bit who
knows 5400 hurts my eyes but maybe it
works bishop before you can just weaken
some squares and say the bishops are
still good yeah that's fair I mean
they're playing for money then right
daddy yeah I mean every game counts for
some cash right
the game comes with some cash the
drawers are okay winds are good just
kidding it's the ratio right 400 goes
the winner and the other 400 is my win
percentage so when there's such a big
discrepancy here it's a little easier to
catch up based on percentage for oh I
don't even know if it works but I love
it
once the position you take back on yeah
I just take the knight on c4 next okay
and you can't cut the visual 187 because
you don't have a bottom on the G fault
there should be four again this is uh
good stuff
solid position this okay take on c4
go for the wind I firoozeh what yeah he
simplifies it out should be a an easy
position to play for two results he
could go full at karo and make this game
last like a hundred fifty moves if he
wanted good nothing he's going to
wouldn't take a check this is back
surprising just get those three pounds
rolling ship d4 threatens he's gonna get
the rooks off the board with rook before
and just make it easy on himself this is
a matter of just the stylistic technique
I guess you know we know he's got smile
style and smiled you can see his
mustache so we know all the resident has
smiles Styles smile styles no okay all
right well he's got he's got styled you
can see the curtains and he's he's gonna
be all smiles after the match to fix my
my slip of the tongue there and now the
a pawns gonna run up the board and this
is close to our last game we got one
more game
for this it's just it gets it gets even
you know random people coming in and she
had right now we're like you know this
is this is getting rough yeah firoozeh
without a doubt as is a heavy favorite
even for like way yeah like the Blitz
portion counts for a lot
but bullet I just I think that's the one
area where you know he could get away
with some of those things that we
thought were maybe mistakes in his game
mistakes with holes it's it's Cara was
in the chat earlier and he said he feels
like faroush is the favorite in the and
the overall JSC see mainly because of
his bullet skills and I don't know that
I agree I think that I think that way ye
is it's still that much stronger just as
a chess player you know and I think that
you know blitz blitz is still the
majority of the portion and you know but
it'll be interesting to see and of
course there's plenty of other players
in the match and I think that you know
we know that everyone is capable of tilt
so it'll be interesting to see how this
shapes up as we get down to some of the
heavy favorites today of course not
Martinez Alcantar is de but he's played
he's played quality chess I think you
know more than the scoreboard would
indicate and and he's still gonna walk
away with some cash right that's like a
consolation prize it's like I feel like
you know Regis Philbin Feldman when
you're like you know but hey you're
still going home with $200 right and
don't forget your gift basket out the
door you know which sure was that
Regis felt we wanted to be a millionaire
yeah it's Pat say check wheel of fortune
Alex Trebek and Regis filming my heroes
hey people misspelled my name all the
time okay Oren
anyway Eric what do you think what
question is one of the questions we got
I think I think we'd all like to ask for
a few questions I mean I don't know I
think you nailed a few of them openings
who you thought you know favourites and
you're right little curious for Martinez
Alcantara how the experience was because
I don't think he's played that often on
a right league stage and now if their
nerves were part of that and right
because I've seen them yeah he plays a
lot online it's always different when
it's like one-on-one for money
sort of thing right you just can't
replicate that particularly easily right
move by move says he likes how the
format actually there's still money on
the line with every game and and that
the cash is split by win percentage
ultimately there's of course a prize for
the winner a base cash prize and then
after that the remaining funds are split
by her many games you went so it you
know again it matches like this where
there's clearly a lopsided victory
happening not what we just experienced
with Ariane tari in your inventories it
went down to the the last seconds which
was awesome but there's gonna be matches
that are both ways but either way
there's cash on the line with every game
and that makes it fun so actually a draw
to bring the time to an end right after
this of course we will have a very very
short break and then bring our players
on for interviews so smarter chance Matt
Jensen says Danny reminds me of my mom
mispronouncing names and picking away
you to win the JSC see well your mom
does one of those things right i'ma let
you decide which one it is because
smarter chess you may be smarter than a
lot of other people but we'll see what
happens when those two
Jr speech s championship wraps up today
when we return
[Music]
and we are back now with both of our
players here the second match of the
year in the junior speeches championship
brought to you by Jessica calm well you
guys great match thank you thank you
both for doing this we have some
questions first for Jose for you if
that's okay
it felt like to start the match in the
beginning there were some games there
were some games that you played very
well but but lost it under time pressure
were you nervous did you did you feel
nervous playing in your first match of
this format yeah
I feel nervous because that one second
increment is is nothing in when I had 30
seconds or less I don't happy that one
second of increment then yeah I played a
good games but firoozeh play very well
in the final of these games so my
advantage is only some moments of the
game but yeah I'm really nervous because
I don't play quite often five five
minutes and it's not my marital right
now you did get a lot of night ORFs that
seemed that seemed to be good was that
was that part of your preparation and
and did you do any preparation for the
match in terms of what you thought you
might be get in the openings again Salih
Reza I prefer something in the kurakin
something in the a45 and the role of is
but I always play natural friend I don't
feel very good too in this match to
played a kurakin defense and well I I
played the neither thing all my games
and maybe 80% of my games but you were
pretty happy with the positions you
as black yeah yeah I may be in the first
game is not a great great position but
it's a quite equal position that in the
third and fifth game with black yeah I
had a good game but in the pressure time
I mean made mistakes mileage and well
euros I win all the games when I made a
mistake over over to you Allah Reza I
guess sticking into the the opening
stage right now you guys were consistent
we see all different types of matches
sometimes with a different opening every
game you guys for the most part had
night Orff's when you were white and Rui
Lopez is when you were black were those
openings that you expected to get and
did you do any preparation for the first
stage of the game in this match yeah
good choice a usual form so you must
drink much better in a regular way these
matches then now I think it was is it is
it mainly just the just the increment
the stage obviously there's a lot on the
line it's not like how you normally just
play blitz for a couple hours right Jose
there's a lot of money on the line is it
just something about the overall format
that just had you feeling a little bit
uneasy not easy to say it's of course a
art form and it's not enjoyable for
players to play because when when you
had that moment where you lost a few
games in a row ali reza and and you kind
of had to find yourself to stop the
bleeding and not go on tilt how do you
how do you hand your handle yourself in
those moments to make sure that you
don't you don't lose too many games in a
row
okay play lots of bulletin pleats in
chess okay I have experience I think -
after - your four losses I get back into
the match so that helped me yeah go
ahead Eric you having well Jose how did
you feel after a few a few of the first
few games you had some pretty good
positions but as you said every time in
the final part of the game it felt like
turning around
how did did you feel you know was it
just you knew that might happen and you
just recovered quickly or just pretty
pretty upset at yourself I tried to
recover because crews have played
borough games and I saw a few magazine
in that he win and he won a camera he
won and it's a strong player of it and
it's difficult to really make a comeback
and but I feel super good with my games
I play very good games others not good
things but well it's a experience well
he just mentioned that you know he's
seen you play bullet against guys like
Nakamura and ali reza you're currently
the highest rated bullet chess player on
chess calm so tell everybody what what
do you think sets you apart from others
in the bullet stage of games the fastest
time control that our species can
generate how do you separate yourself at
that time control that's for you of
course I play lots of course
it's it's fair to say that it's fair to
say that Eric Hanson is your toughest
opponent right then I get to an 800
because let's talk about the format
overall a lot of a lot of people see you
as the heavy favorite because of your
experience on chefs calm and because of
how good you are in Bullitt do you
consider yourself the favorite to win
the junior speeches championship okay I
am one of the favorites of course but
there's lots of good players in this
tournament so it's not easy but I had a
question Danny about a couple of the
draws well it was there a connection
issue there's a couple drawers I I
missed was there something behind that
is of course it was very good from him
that give me that throw because I must
disconnect it okay okay
Jose that's a very it was a very classy
thing to do we've had people play these
formats who didn't who didn't give a
draw when their opponent disconnected so
that was a very good sportsmanship thing
to do there it's a legal action I can
play when my opponent have one second
two seconds no then a very purple a no
right well you um
you're you're a lot of a lot of what
we're doing here is is also allowing the
fans to get to know some of the top
young chess players in the world and and
you're actually currently studying
pursuing a degree in communication and
journalism right yeah two years ago I
started to study journalism but in 2017
I left the university for one year maybe
and come back to the tournaments because
I I didn't play anything in 2015
mm
damn nothing tournament and oh I played
very good games in the world under-18
championship and other other tournaments
for exemple it's some tournament I play
a very good well you play very well and
congratulations and best of luck
pursuing your degree ali reza
congratulations to you from moving on i
already asked you if you think you're
the favorite i'll ask you one other
question who do you think it would be
the toughest challenge for you in this
format of the players in it i think okay
interesting we'll keep our eye on that
we'll keep our eye on both you guys
honestly this was a lot of fun for the
fans and this is we have thousands of
viewers here ruined you guys on it's
been a really exciting day we appreciate
it
i'm gonna say goodbye to both you i know
it's late there for you ali reza and
again late for you as well thank you
guys and have a have a good evening
there okay bye alright well as we as we
say goodbye to our players on the day
eric you and i get to look ahead and do
our quick best guess at making
predictions i'll ask you what do you
think prague non-data needs to do to
give way ye a challenge in the 16 versus
1 matchup that's coming up on May 31st
yeah well I think bullet is always up
for grabs don't think way he has that
much time to play bullet because he's
busy trying to play tournament site you
know right now the feed a Graham free
and probably take advantage of the fact
that okay way like like playing some
more offbeat openings not challenging
the main lines just take when we see
matches between players who who play a
lot of traditional tournaments and
players who have looks a more online
play I mean there's there's a different
styles and and you can take advantage of
the fact that you know you're playing
someone who's used to playing good moves
but not used to like some of the
trickiness that goes online so I think
you just needs to take the fight to
they play avoid some of the things that
someone you'd expect like we need to be
that like me and my night or things like
that and just to be as tricky as
possible all right try to get it into a
dirty little speed speedfest
well I gotta say that chess bra polo
looks good on you is the chest out comp
uh looks on you material I was gonna say
that looks cute with what all III feel
so honored you got dressed up for me
today well everybody else who showed up
we feel honored to have you seriously
this is the greatest job in the world
thank you to everyone we are about to
descend the show over to Grand Master
you love big hammer if you don't follow
his channel on twitch you should so
stick around as we send the raid off the
hype is real give give him or your love
give them your follow and on behalf of
everybody here at chest come behind the
scenes making this happen as well as my
co-pilot here Grandmaster Eric Hanson
thanks for watching the junior speeches
championship brought to you by chest kid
and we will see you for another J SCC on
May 31st good night everybody
good night everyone
[Music]